Avant que la vidéo ne commence, j’ai une
question à vous poser :
Vous croyez VRAIMENT que les gens ont lu tous
les livres dont ils parlent ?
Bien sûr que non — sinon on ne pourrait
pas parler de grand-chose.
Eh oui, il y a vingt-quatre heures dans une
journée, et il faut travailler, manger, dormir,
et sortir le chien.
Donc le secret de la culture générale, ce
n’est PAS de lire des livres.
C’est quoi alors ?
Eh bien en fait, il n’y a pas qu’un seul
secret, il y en a CINQ.
Les étudiants et les personnes les plus cultivés,
les profs, et les intellectuels CONNAISSENT
ces cinq secrets, mais ils se gardent bien
d’en parler…
Les gens qui les découvrent réussissent
à développer RAPIDEMENT et FACILEMENT leur
culture générale, parce que leur rapport
au savoir A CHANGÉ.
Et une fois qu’ils APPLIQUENT les cinq secrets,
ils comprennent toutes les références des
personnes cultivées ;
ils savent s’exprimer avec profondeur sur
n’importe quel sujet ;
ils brillent par leur culture dans les conversations
et dans les débats ;
et ils ont le recul nécessaire pour faire
preuve d’esprit critique.
Ça vous intéresse ?
Eh bien je vous révèle les cinq secrets,
et je vous explique comment les appliquer
DÈS AUJOURD’HUI
pour vous cultiver DIX FOIS PLUS RAPIDEMENT
SANS VOUS PRENDRE LA TÊTE.
Pour recevoir les cinq secrets, inscrivez-vous
simplement soit en cliquant sur le lien qui
apparaît maintenant en haut à droite de
la vidéo, soit en cliquant sur celui qui
est dans la description de la vidéo.
C’est l’histoire de 10 secondes, donc
faites-le maintenant,
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier secret,
qui vous attendra bien au chaud dans votre
boîte mail après avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà, je vous ai dit ce que je voulais
vous dire.
Bonne vidéo !
1ère référence : Don Quichotte (1605),
Miguel de Cervantes
Il y a plus de quinze ans, j’ai eu une conversation
passionnante dans un hôtel miteux — ce
qu’on appelle un hostel — de Los Angeles.
Mon interlocuteur était un homme dans la
cinquantaine. Il portait des lunettes et s’exprimait
lentement, en choisissant ses mots avec soin.
Manifestement, il avait beaucoup lu — notamment
Platon, dont il avait tiré des leçons profondes
sur la politique. Lorsque je lui ai demandé
quelles études il avait faites, il m’a
répondu : « J’ai passé plusieurs années
en prison. Je n’avais rien d’autre à
faire que lire. » En effet, la prison est
un contexte exceptionnel qui favorise la méditation,
la lecture et l’écriture — des activités
qui demandent beaucoup discipline et de concentration
dans un contexte normal.
Miguel de Cervantes dit qu’il a eu l’idée
de son roman Don Quichotte en prison. Il y
a effectué plusieurs séjours parce qu’il
avait une fâcheuse tendance à vouloir tirer
un profit personnel de sa position de fonctionnaire
de la couronne espagnole. Il aurait détourné
des biens de l’Église ; il aurait vendu
du blé destiné à l’armée ; et lorsqu’il
était percepteur d’impôts, il n’aurait
remis qu’une partie seulement de la somme
collectée. La prison n’est qu’une des
mésaventures de Cervantes. Au moment où
il se met à écrire Don Quichotte, sa vie
n’a été qu’une succession d’errances
et d’échecs. Il a été capturé par des
pirates, qui l’ont gardé pendant cinq ans
; il a perdu l’usage de sa main gauche à
la guerre contre les Ottomans, après quoi
les gens se moquent de lui parce qu’il est
manchot ; il a galéré financièrement et
même connu la pauvreté ; il n’est pas
parvenu à vivre de sa plume ; et pour couronner
le tout, il s’est fait prendre pour la plupart
de ses combines.
Mais son destin bascule à 57 ans. C’est
en effet à cet âge avancé qu’il écrit
un des livres les plus importants de toute
la culture occidentale.
Don Quichotte est en effet le premier roman
moderne. À l’hiver 1605, au cœur de l’empire
le plus puissant du monde, qui connaît alors
un déclin économique et la stagnation politique
— à cette époque, des rumeurs circulent
à propos d’un livre. Les librairies se
retrouvent rapidement en rupture de stock
; ceux qui savent lire se prêtent des copies
de plus en plus usées ; et ceux qui ne savent
pas lire se rassemblent dans les auberges,
les places de village et les tavernes pour
écouter la lecture à haute voix. La toute
première édition est épuisée deux mois
seulement après la sortie.
Le titre complet de ce roman est L’Ingénieux
Hidalgo Don Quichotte de la Manche, mais on
l’abrège généralement en Don Quichotte.
On en dit qu’il est le livre le plus vendu
de tous les temps après la Bible, ce qui
fait de Cervantes, un pauvre vétéran de
guerre du début du XVIIe siècle, manchot,
presque sans dents — cet homme qui n’a
connu que l’échec devient avec ce roman
l’auteur le plus lu de toute l’histoire
de l’humanité.
Que dire de la forme de ce roman ?
Le livre fait en tout — en comptant les
deux parties — plus de 1000 pages (et même
plutôt 1200-1300) dans une édition classique
sans annotations ni commentaires. Donc ce
n’est pas l’histoire d’un voyage en
train. Après, la prose de Cervantes est plutôt
accessible dans les traductions récentes.
Les chapitres sont brefs ; le style est relativement
simple, même direct. Mais d’un autre côté,
les paragraphes sont parfois bien longs ; de
même pour les phrases, qui peuvent contenir
plusieurs points-virgules. Le lecteur de 2023
risque de manquer de vocabulaire même dans
les versions modernisées, et Cervantes évoque
parfois des références culturelles qui peuvent
nécessiter des allers-retours sur Wikipedia.
Enfin, la structure innovante du roman (qui
imbrique des histoires) complique encore la
tâche. En conclusion, ce roman est lisible
pour un adulte cultivé et motivé — mais
ça me paraît compliqué pour un adolescent
de 2023.
Je vous résume rapidement l’intrigue.
Don Quichotte est un pauvre Espagnol de petite
noblesse. Liseur fanatique de romans de chevalerie,
il décide d’imiter son modèle, le plus
grand des chevaliers errants. Il s'équipe
d'une vieille armure et monte sur son maigre
cheval, qu'il nomme Rossinante. Il prend à
son service un paysan qui monte un âne, Sancho
Panza. Il l’a décidé à l’accompagner
en lui promettant une île à gouverner. Comme
les modèles de ses romans, Don Quichotte
se dépasse pour une « princesse », nommée
Dulcinée — qui est en réalité une paysanne
ordinaire de la région que Don Quichotte
n’a jamais rencontrée.
Convaincu de sa mission chevaleresque, Don
Quichotte décide de parcourir l'Espagne pour
combattre l'injustice. Ses aventures se déroulent
principalement dans sa région d’origine,
située au centre de l’Espagne (au sud de
Madrid), la Manche (le nom complet de Don
Quichotte est d’ailleurs « Don Quichotte
de la Manche »). L’aventure la plus célèbre
est racontée dans le chapitre VIII : Don
Quichotte se bat contre des « géants », qui
ne sont, en réalité, que des moulins à
vent. Cet épisode a inspiré l’expression
idiomatique « se battre contre des moulins
à vent », qui signifie lutter contre des
choses illusoires ou poursuivre un objectif
inatteignable (on peut dire par exemple « essayer
de réduire l'influence des smartphones revient
à se battre contre des moulins à vent »).
Parmi les aventures emblématiques, il y a
encore l’épisode de la libération des
galériens. Don Quichotte croise un groupe
de prisonniers enchaînés en route pour les
galères. Il les libère, pensant qu'ils ont
été injustement punis, mais les galériens
se retournent contre lui lorsqu’il leur
ordonne d’aller raconter son acte à sa
princesse imaginaire. Enfin, un autre épisode
emblématique est celui de la grotte de Montesinos.
Don Quichotte descend dans une grotte ; il
s’y endort et rêve de sa princesse imaginaire.
Cet épisode est une allusion au motif de
la descente aux enfers dans les récits légendaires
(le héros visite le monde des morts, et il
en revient transformé, mûr pour la suite
de ses aventures).
La relation de Don Quichotte et Sancho Panza
évolue au fil de leurs aventures. Leur simple
association initiale de maître et serviteur
devient une amitié profonde. Cela fait qu’ils
s’influencent mutuellement. Le serviteur
adopte un peu l’idéal chevaleresque de
son maître, tandis que celui-ci adopte à
certains moments le pragmatisme de son serviteur.
Leur relation incarne la dynamique de l’idéalisme
et du réalisme.
Enfin, comme je l’ai dit, la structure du
roman est un peu compliquée. Les personnages
rencontrés par Don Quichotte et Sancho Panza
racontent leurs propres histoires, ce qui
crée un récit à plusieurs niveaux (c’était
une innovation littéraire pour l’époque).
Autre innovation, Cervantes intègre habilement
sa propre présence dans le roman (surtout
dans la seconde partie, publiée 10 ans après
la première). Cervantès se sert de ce procédé
pour commenter son propre travail et celui
des imitateurs de la première partie. Cela
correspond également au thème profond du
roman, les frontières de la réalité et
de la fiction.
Maintenant, que dire concernant l’importance
et l’influence de ce roman ?
Des livres entiers ont été écrits sur cette
question — si vous voulez creuser, je vous
recommande The Man Who Invented Fiction de
William Egginton, qui est prof de littérature
dans une université américaine pas loin
de Washington (ce livre n’a pas été traduit
en français, ce qui confirme ce que j’ai
dit dans plusieurs vidéos : vous devez absolument
être capable de lire des livres en anglais
si vous voulez élargir votre horizon intellectuel
avec tout ce qu’internet, et plus généralement
le monde moderne a à offrir). Comme des livres
entiers ont été écrits à propos de l’influence
de Don Quichotte dans la culture occidentale,
je vais me contenter d’évoquer les trois
dimensions essentielles de cette influence.
Tout d’abord, avec ce roman, Cervantès
crée une nouvelle manière de produire de
la fiction. L’innovation primordiale de
cette nouvelle manière de faire, c’est
le jeu subtil avec les frontières de la réalité
et de la fiction. Le romancier doit permettre
au lecteur de se dissocier en deux identités
: d’un côté, le lecteur sait que l’histoire
est inventée ; mais en même temps, il fait
comme s’il croyait à l’histoire le temps
de la lecture. Cet effet spécial sera baptisé
« suspension de l’incrédulité » ou « foi
poétique » par le poète britannique du
tournant du XIXe siècle Samuel Taylor Coleridge
dans son autobiographie. La « suspension
de l’incrédulité », cela signifie que
si l’écrivain réussit à infuser dans
son œuvre « un semblant de vérité » suffisant,
alors il permet au lecteur de suspendre momentanément
son incrédulité pour s'immerger pleinement
dans le monde fictif de l'histoire. C’est
notamment en créant des personnages profonds
et nuancés — ce qui distingue son roman
des œuvres littéraires antérieures — que
Cervantès permet au lecteur de s'investir
émotionnellement malgré les péripéties
extravagantes de l’histoire. William Egginton
(le prof de littérature américain que j’ai
mentionné il y a une minute) — William
Egginton estime que Cervantès a révolutionné
la fiction parce qu’il a écrit beaucoup
de pièces de théâtre avant d’écrire
Don Quichotte. En effet, le théâtre, grâce
à la représentation visuelle directe des
personnages et des décors, facilite plus
efficacement la suspension de l'incrédulité
du spectateur. Cervantès aurait donc importé
du théâtre l’idée qu’un personnage
peut être crédible sans être réel.
La deuxième dimension de l’influence de
ce roman, c’est qu’il représente une
révolution narrative. Autrement dit, Cervantès
crée une nouvelle manière de raconter l’histoire.
Il mélange différents genres littéraires
(notamment le roman de chevalerie [qu’il
parodie], la satire et en même temps le roman
picaresque, genre qui consiste à raconter
les aventures d'un personnage de basse extraction,
le Picaro, se déplaçant à travers la société
et offrant un commentaire critique sur ses
différents échelons). Cervantès innove
également sur le plan de la narration en
introduisant la technique de la mise en abyme
(une histoire dans l’histoire) ; et plus
généralement en remettant en question la
structure traditionnelle du récit.
Enfin, la troisième dimension essentielle
de l’influence de ce roman est que son protagoniste
deviendra un personnage mythique dans l’imaginaire
occidental. Il symbolise la folie de l’idéalisme.
« Don Quichotte » est d’ailleurs devenu
un nom commun en français : on dit un « Don
Quichotte » ou un « Quichotte » pour qualifier
une personne qui fait preuve d’un idéalisme
naïf, et qui est généreuse dans sa volonté
de redresser les torts (on peut aussi dire
que cette personne est « donquichottesque
»). Don Quichotte est également un mythe
qui symbolise l’influence pernicieuse de
la fiction. Comme d’autres grands auteurs
de la culture occidentale (je pense notamment
à Rousseau), Cervantès met en évidence
le fait que la fiction nous inspire des désirs
déraisonnables (c’est pourquoi, dans l’intrigue,
le curé et le barbier du village de Don Quichotte,
conscients de l’origine du problème, brûlent
ses livres). Flaubert dira la même chose
sur l’influence de la fiction, mais sur
un ton sérieux, dans Madame Bovary. René
Girard — auquel j’ai consacré mon mémoire
de philosophie à la Sorbonne — René Girard
proposera une interprétation plus précise
de l’intrigue de Don Quichotte dans Mensonge
romantique et vérité romanesque : pour René
Girard, Cervantès révélerait la nature
mimétique du désir humain. Don Quichotte
se lance dans ses aventures pour imiter les
modèles qu’il a découverts dans les romans
de chevalerie. Et en réalité, nous faisons
tous la même chose, mais à un degré moindre
qui ne relève pas de la folie.
Au-delà du roman lui-même, Don Quichotte
a été repris, adapté et réinterprété
depuis quatre siècles dans de nombreuses
œuvres d'art, de théâtre, de musique, et
de cinéma. Et René Girard n’est qu’un
des penseurs à avoir donné une interprétation
du sens profond du roman. Pour Michel Foucault,
par exemple, Don Quichotte représente le
moment où le langage et les signes ont cessé
de refléter la réalité. Autre exemple : Benoît
XVI a écrit (avant de devenir pape) que Don
Quichotte symbolise la fin de la mentalité
du Moyen Âge.
Ce qui est certain, c’est qu’il fallait
un homme profondément original pour écrire
ce livre d’une profonde originalité pour
l’époque.
2ème référence : Les Voyages de Gulliver
(1726), Jonathan Swift
La spéculation sur les crypto-monnaies fait
parfois passer les casinos pour un placement
de père de famille. Je connais par exemple
quelqu’un qui a eu la chance de transformer
des milliers d’euros en des millions en
quelques jours. Et il existe bien sûr des
histoires dans l’autre sens. Les crypto-monnaies
concentrent en un laps de temps bien plus
court ce qui se produit depuis qu’il y a
des bulles et des krachs. À la fin 1720,
par exemple, se produit en Grande-Bretagne
un des premiers krachs de l’histoire. Les
actions de la compagnie britannique détentrice
du monopole du commerce avec les colonies
espagnoles en Amérique — les actions de
cette entreprise s’effondrent. Jonathan
Swift, qui est à la fois écrivain et chef
d’une cathédrale de Dublin (la capitale
de l’Irlande) — Jonathan Swift avait acheté
les actions à leur prix initial près de
10 ans plus tôt. Il a donc vu leur valeur
gonfler jusqu’à être multipliée par huit
; puis retomber à son niveau initial en quelques
mois.
C’est cette montagne russe qui aurait inspiré
à Swift l’idée du roman qu’il écrira
un an plus tard, Les Voyages de Gulliver.
Pour l’expliquer plus précisément, la
valeur boursière qui gonfle et qui dégonfle
rapidement aurait inspiré à Swift l’idée
d’un personnage qui change de taille en
fonction du pays dans lequel il se rend.
Les Voyages de Gulliver est un, sinon LE roman
satirique de référence dans la littérature
mondiale. Il sera un modèle pour les écrivains
ultérieurs de fiction en prose qui voudront
s’adonner à la satire, c’est-à-dire
critiquer la société en s’en moquant.
Sur la forme, ce n’est pas un roman interminable
: il fait entre 200 et 300 pages selon les
éditions. Comme l’indique le titre, l’histoire
est subdivisée en voyages : il y en a quatre.
C’est lisible même dans les premières
traductions. Écrit à la première personne
du singulier, avec Gulliver comme narrateur,
ce roman favorise la connexion émotionnelle
du lecteur. La lecture est également facilitée
par le fait que Swift alterne entre des phrases
longues et courtes, tout comme il varie la
longueur des paragraphes. Le vocabulaire est
parfois désuet, mais il reste dans l’ensemble
compréhensible.
Maintenant, je vous résume rapidement chacun
des quatre voyages.
Imaginez-vous vous réveiller, attaché au
sol, par des êtres minuscules ! C'est ce
qui arrive à Gulliver lorsqu'il échoue sur
l'île de Lilliput. Les habitants, hauts de
15 centimètres, le voient donc comme un géant.
Étant donné cette différence, Gulliver
devient un outil politique pour le roi de
Lilliput, impliqué dans une guerre absurde
contre le pays voisin. Pourquoi « absurde
» ? Parce que le motif est un désaccord
sur la façon de casser les œufs ! Après
avoir aidé Lilliput contre ses ennemis, Gulliver
finit par déplaire et doit fuir.
Ce premier voyage est le plus célèbre, celui
qui a imprégné la culture populaire. Le
nom de l’île de Lilliput a donné l’adjectif
et nom commun « lilliputien », qui désigne
une chose, plus souvent une personne, minuscule
(je peux par exemple dire que mon chihuahua
est un lilliputien comparé au labrador du
voisin).
Deuxième voyage : Gulliver arrive à Brobdingnag,
un pays de géants. C’est donc lui, désormais,
l’être minuscule. D'abord exposé comme
une curiosité, il est ensuite adopté par
la reine. Ces géants, malgré leur taille,
sont doux et bienveillants. Ils voient la
société européenne que leur décrit Gulliver
comme violente et corrompue. Le séjour de
Gulliver chez les géants prend fin lorsqu’un
aigle l’emporte.
Il atterrit sur une île volante, Laputa.
Les habitants de cette île sont des penseurs
et des rêveurs, obnubilés par la musique
et les mathématiques (ce qui est une référence
à la philosophie très abstraite de Platon).
Ces gens sont-ils vraiment si intelligents
? Ils semblent incapables de gérer les problèmes
pratiques du quotidien. Gulliver visite également
le continent, nommé « Balnibarbi », situé
directement sous l'île volante. Il découvre
des projets scientifiques ridicules, tel celui
d'enfermer les rayons du soleil dans des concombres
!
Enfin, lors de son dernier voyage, Gulliver
découvre les Houyhnhnms, des chevaux dotés
de raison et de sagesse. Ces chevaux dominent
des créatures repoussantes et brutales, dont
Gulliver comprend qu’ils sont en réalité
des êtres humains, les « Yahoos » (c’est
de là que vient le nom de « Yahoo », le
portail internet populaire au tournant des
années 2000, mais aujourd’hui largement
éclipsé par Google). Craignant que la présence
de Gulliver ne corrompe leur société, les
chevaux intelligents lui demandent de partir
(Swift dénonce par là le manque d’empathie
des personnes les plus rationnelles). Gulliver
rentre donc en Angleterre, où il sera amer
envers l'humanité.
Comment expliquer l’influence de ce roman
dans la littérature et la culture occidentales
?
Les Voyages de Gulliver a exercé une influence
majeure à trois niveaux :
1. Il popularise le genre de la satire. Swift
critique par exemple la futilité des motifs
de guerre, et plus généralement la vanité
humaine (qui est sensible au pays des géants).
Swift inspirera d’autres auteurs à se servir
de la littérature comme outil de commentaire
social (Voltaire et Orwell sont parmi ses
plus célèbres héritiers).
2. Deuxième niveau de l’influence de ce
livre : l’image du géant chez des créatures
minuscules a intégré l’imaginaire collectif
occidental. Comme elle est amusante, elle
a notamment été reprise dans de nombreux
livres pour enfants (c’est aussi la raison
pour laquelle Les Voyages de Gulliver est
souvent considéré — à tort — comme
un roman pour enfants).
3. Enfin, troisième niveau de l’influence
des Voyages de Gulliver : ce n’est pas un
roman pour enfants parce qu’il contient
des réflexions profondes sur la condition
humaine (sur le pouvoir, la morale et la place
de l’homme dans l’univers). Il enrichit
donc le genre littéraire du conte philosophique.
Comme Montesquieu dans les Lettres persanes,
et plus tard Voltaire dans Candide, Swift
mise lui aussi sur le procédé narratif consistant
à comparer différents mondes pour faire
ressortir les travers de la société européenne.
3ème référence : Les Souffrances du jeune
Werther (1774), Goethe
Peu après la publication de ce livre en 1774,
plusieurs régions d’Europe l’interdisent.
Il ne s’agit pourtant pas d’un pamphlet
politique — le thème central est l’amour.
Comment expliquer la censure ? En fait, les
autorités veulent arrêter un phénomène
de contagion déclenché par le roman. Beaucoup
de jeunes hommes se sont mis à imiter le
héros du roman. Ils imitent d’abord son
style vestimentaire en portant des vestes
jaunes et des pantalons bleus. Puis une partie
d’entre eux décident de pousser l’imitation
jusqu’à… mettre fin à leurs jours. Le
suicide par pistolet devient une méthode
courante. Certains jeunes hommes laissent
même une copie du livre à leurs côtés
ou des notes faisant référence au roman.
Le protagoniste, Werther, est un modèle contagieux
à l’origine d’une vague de suicides préoccupante
pour les autorités. C’est en référence
à ce personnage que les psychologues baptiseront
« effet Werther » la possible influence
des médias sur les comportements suicidaires
(si les médias évoquent le suicide d’une
célébrité, par exemple, cela risque d’inspirer
des personnes suicidaires à passer à l’acte
elles aussi).
Pour faire simple, ce roman est incontournable
parce qu’il est la référence en matière
de représentation littéraire des sentiments.
Il exprime les tourments émotionnels de la
passion (amoureuse, en l’occurrence) avec
une intensité et un réalisme inégalés.
Cela a fait du personnage de Werther une sorte
de miroir dans lequel des générations de
jeunes lecteurs ont vu leurs propres tourments
— d’où le mimétisme que j’ai évoqué.
C’est parce qu’il est la référence en
matière de représentation littéraire des
sentiments que ce roman inaugure le mouvement
littéraire allemand Sturm und Drang (« Tempête
et Passion » en français) qui conteste les
Lumières et la suprématie de la raison.
Cela fait de ce roman un des textes fondateurs
du romantisme, le courant culturel européen
des XVIIIe-XIXe siècles qui valorise le sentiment
en réaction contre l’esprit du classicisme
et des Lumières. On peut aussi dire que Les
Souffrances du jeune Werther est le roman
de référence, dans la littérature occidentale,
sur le thème du chagrin d’amour.
Enfin, ce livre est également important parce
que son succès dans l’Europe entière établit
d’un seul coup la gloire de Goethe. Goethe
est le plus grand nom de la littérature de
langue allemande (puisqu’on dit de cette
langue que c’est « la langue de Goethe
» comme on dit du français qu’il est « la
langue de Molière » [on peut aussi dire
« de Voltaire »] et comme on dit de l’anglais
qu’il est « la langue de Shakespeare »). Peut-être
savez-vous aussi que l’Allemagne a installé
des instituts Goethe à travers le monde entier
pour développer son soft power (c’est dire
l’importance de Goethe pour les Allemands).
Que dire de la forme de ce roman ?
Avec un peu plus de 200 pages, ce n’est
pas un pavé. Il compile des lettres de Werther
principalement adressées à son ami et confident
Wilhelm (il parle donc à la première personne
du singulier et il tutoie son confident).
Le choix par Goethe de la forme épistolaire
rend le propos intime, ce qui a l’avantage
de permettre au lecteur de se plonger directement
dans l'esprit tourmenté de Werther. Le style
est plutôt clair. Bien sûr, la prose paraîtra
surannée à un lecteur de 2023, mais ça
reste compréhensible. Goethe combine des
phrases plutôt courtes pour décrire l’action
ou de simples observations, et des phrases
longues et complexes pour exprimer des moments
de passion. La taille des paragraphes varie
également. Enfin, le vocabulaire est riche.
C’est donc globalement accessible, mais
j’avais trouvé la sentimentalité du style
assez lourde lorsque j’avais lu ce roman
il y a 15 ans (alors que j’étais moi-même
plutôt une personne sensible).
Maintenant, je vous résume rapidement l’intrigue.
Werther, un jeune artiste au tempérament
sensible et passionné, arrive dans le paisible
village de Wahlheim. Séduit par la vie simple
et authentique des villageois, il s'intègre
rapidement. Il croise le chemin de Charlotte.
Cette jeune femme, belle et douce, prend soin
de ses frères et sœurs depuis le décès
tragique de leur mère. Touché par sa gentillesse
et sa grâce, Werther tombe profondément
amoureux d'elle. Cependant, un obstacle — et
pas des moindres — se dresse devant lui
: Charlotte est déjà fiancée à Albert.
Malgré son amour non partagé, Werther, qui
ne pouvait pas consulter les chaînes YouTube
des coachs en séduction — Werther tente
de nouer une amitié avec le couple Charlotte-Albert
— mais la douleur est trop forte. Il quitte
donc Wahlheim pour Weimar, où il est rejeté
par l'aristocratie locale. De retour à Wahlheim,
son chagrin s'intensifie, car Charlotte est
maintenant mariée à Albert. Après une visite
émotionnelle chez elle, Werther décide que
l'un des trois doit mourir. Incapable de faire
du mal à Charlotte ou à Albert, il décide
donc de se suicider. Il écrit une lettre
d'adieu, demande les pistolets d'Albert, puis
se tire une balle. Il meurt seul douze heures
plus tard et sera enterré sans cérémonie
(le suicide étant un péché grave dans la
tradition chrétienne). Charlotte est dévastée.
Les Souffrances du jeune Werther est un roman
très influent dans la littérature, et plus
largement dans la culture occidentale.
Voici les 3 principales raisons de son influence
:
1. Comme je l’ai dit au début, ce roman
est un des textes fondateurs du romantisme.
Goethe décrit la transcendance de l’amour
et la quête d’absolu qui animent Werther.
Il livre une analyse extrêmement fine des
tourments intérieurs de son personnage, qui
incarne l’idéal romantique.
2. Ensuite, Les Souffrances du jeune Werther
est devenu un modèle de ce qu’on appelle
le roman « personnel » ou « intime ». Ce
genre inspiré par Les Confessions de Rousseau
consiste en ce que le romancier partage ses
états d’âme à travers un personnage qui
lui ressemble beaucoup. Il y aura aussi des
exemples fameux en France, comme René de
Chateaubriand, Louis Lambert de Balzac, ou
La Confession d'un enfant du siècle de Musset.
3. Enfin, le destin de Werther est devenu
un mythe dans la culture occidentale. Il symbolise
l’amour impossible et la souffrance psychologique
qui en découle. Les contemporains du roman
ne l’ont pas pris comme cela, mais peut-être
peut-on dire, avec le recul, que le suicide
de Werther symbolise l’échec de l’idéal
romantique en amour, et plus généralement
du rapport sentimental à l’existence.
4ème référence : Orgueil et Préjugés
(1813), Jane Austen
Edmund Wilson, un critique littéraire américain
qui compte parmi les critiques littéraires
les plus importants du XXe siècle — Edmund
Wilson estime que seuls deux auteurs n’ont
pas été affectés par les évolutions du
goût du public depuis le XIXe siècle : il
y a bien sûr Shakespeare, le géant de la
littérature anglaise ; et… Jane Austen.
Ce roman en particulier, Orgueil et Préjugés,
finit systématiquement aux premières places
dans les sondages réalisés au XXe siècle
à propos des meilleurs romans anglais. Sa
première édition, celle de 1813, a été
épuisée en seulement un an, et il n’a
jamais cessé d’être imprimé depuis.
Pour faire simple, ce roman est incontournable
dans la littérature occidentale parce qu’il
est la référence sur le thème du statut
social. Il symbolise plus précisément la
rigidité de la société bourgeoise (britannique,
tout particulièrement) du XIXe siècle. Comme
le suggère son titre, il offre une critique
des conventions qui emprisonnaient les individus,
en particulier les femmes, dans des rôles
stéréotypés. L’autrice, Jane Austen,
est elle-même victime des conventions : le
livre est publié anonymement parce qu’en
tant que femme de la bonne société, Austen
ne peut pas revendiquer le statut d’écrivain.
Sur le plan de la forme, c’est un épais
roman de 500 pages. Le style de Jane Austen
est clair, vif et ironique ; le vocabulaire
n’est pas compliqué, tout à fait compréhensible
pour un lecteur de 2023. La lecture est d’autant
plus facile que le texte consiste essentiellement
en des dialogues. Il y a très peu de descriptions,
et presque aucun contexte sociopolitique,
ce qui a d’ailleurs été reproché au roman.
Les chapitres sont courts, donc la lecture
peut être facilement morcelée. De mon point
de vue, le seul défaut de style est que les
phrases sont parfois longues (mais bon, on
attendait cela des auteurs de l’époque).
Je vous résume rapidement l’histoire.
Elle se déroule principalement dans un comté
situé à environ 80 km au nord de Londres.
Elle met en scène la famille Bennet, avec
ses cinq filles, dont la vive et perspicace
Elizabeth, qui est la protagoniste du roman.
Les Bennet appartiennent à la classe sociale
des propriétaires de petits domaines ou de
terres à la campagne, classe qu’on appelle
la « petite gentry rurale » (« gentry » peut
être traduit par « noblesse terrienne » en
français). Les Bennet occupent une position
respectable dans la société, sans pour autant
avoir le prestige ou la richesse des grandes
familles aristocratiques.
Le mariage est un enjeu crucial pour cette
famille, parce qu’en vertu des lois de l’époque,
les filles ne pas peuvent hériter de la propriété
familiale (qui passera probablement à un
cousin éloigné à la mort des parents).
Si les Bennet avaient eu au moins un fils,
celui-ci aurait hérité de la propriété
et aurait pu (théoriquement) soutenir financièrement
ses sœurs grâce aux ressources tirées de
la propriété. Mais comme les Bennet n’ont
que des filles, celles-ci doivent se marier
afin d’assurer leur sécurité financière
personnelle.
Cette préoccupation se retrouve dans l’ouverture
du roman, qui est une des plus célèbres
de la littérature anglaise : « C’est une
vérité universellement reconnue qu’un
célibataire pourvu d’une belle fortune
doit être en quête d’une épouse. »
L’intrigue commence en effet avec l'arrivée
de Mr. Bingley. Ce célibataire fortuné s’installe
près de la famille d’Elizabeth. Mrs. Bennet
voit en lui un prétendant idéal pour l'une
de ses filles. Et lors d'un bal, Jane, l'aînée
des Bennet, attire l'attention de Bingley.
En parallèle, Elizabeth croise le chemin
de Mr. Darcy, un ami de Bingley. Ce Mr. Darcy,
avec son attitude hautaine, repousse d'emblée
Elizabeth. Son arrogance incarne le titre
du roman.
L’histoire se complique avec l'introduction
de Mr. Wickham, un militaire charmant mais
mystérieux. Il confie à Elizabeth ses démêlés
avec Darcy, ce qui entraîne la jeune femme
à se méfier encore davantage de l’homme
qui l’a marquée par son orgueil. Mais lors
d'une visite chez une amie, Elizabeth recroise
Darcy. Et contre toute attente, il la demande
en mariage. Mais elle refuse. Elle lui reproche
d’être impliqué dans la séparation de
sa sœur Jane avec Bingley (le célibataire
fortuné qui est arrivé au début de l’histoire),
et elle lui reproche également son conflit
avec Wickham. Darcy lui écrit alors une lettre
pour se défendre. Dans cette lettre, il dévoile
notamment la véritable nature de Wickham.
Et c’est ce personnage qui porte le drame
à son apogée. Lydia, la cadette des Bennet,
s'enfuit avec Wickham. Le déshonneur menace
la famille. Heureusement, Darcy intervient
en secret pour sauver la réputation des Bennet
: il assure le mariage de Lydia et Wickham.
Ce dénouement change l’opinion qu’Elizabeth
a de Darcy. Lorsque leurs chemins se croisent
à nouveau, ils se marient. Cette fin heureuse
symbolise l'union de deux classes sociales
et la victoire de l'amour sur les préjugés.
Que retenir de l’influence de ce roman dans
la littérature et la culture occidentales
?
En premier lieu, Orgueil et Préjugés est
emblématique d’un sous-genre du roman réaliste,
le roman de mœurs. Comme le nom le suggère,
le roman de mœurs se concentre sur les mœurs
d’un milieu social particulier. Jane Austen
dépeint avec finesse et humour les relations,
les mariages, les préoccupations financières
et les attentes sociales de la classe d’Elizabeth,
la petite gentry rurale du début du XIXe
siècle. Dans cette perspective, on peut dire
de ce roman, comme on dit de ceux de Balzac,
que c’est de la sociologie avant l’heure.
Une autre dimension essentielle de l’influence
de ce livre est la libération de la femme.
En effet, avec son héroïne, Jane Austen
donne à des générations de lectrices un
modèle de femme à l’esprit indépendant,
vive et intègre. La société attend d’Elizabeth
qu’elle se marie pour la sécurité financière,
mais elle préfère suivre son cœur et son
jugement.
Enfin, le roman a plus largement influencé
la culture occidentale. C’est une des histoires
emblématiques, dans l’imaginaire collectif,
de la question du statut social envisagée
sous l’angle de l’amour. Que Jane Austen
soit restée si vague sur le contexte de son
intrigue s’est finalement révélé un avantage
: les thèmes et les personnalités ont un
caractère universel grâce auquel ils continuent
d’intéresser les lecteurs modernes. Le
roman a fait l'objet d'innombrables adaptations
et modernisations, allant des pièces de théâtre
aux films et séries télévisées, en passant
par les comédies musicales. L’histoire
de Jane Austen a connu une telle popularité
et elle a été déclinée sous tant de formes
que certains disent qu’Orgueil et Préjugés
est une industrie culturelle à lui seul.
5ème référence : Oliver Twist (1837), Charles
Dickens
Plusieurs auteurs ont remarqué que les grandes
leçons de l’œuvre de Marx étaient déjà
dans la littérature de fiction du XIXe siècle.
Par exemple, certains disent que « tout Marx
est dans Balzac » (d’ailleurs Marx aimait
les romans de Balzac). Charles Dickens, un
Anglais, écrit à peu près au même moment
que Balzac. Et le philosophe Alain dit à
propos de ce roman, Oliver Twist, qui sort
trente ans avant Le Capital de Marx : « Il
n’y a pas tant de différence entre ce noir
tableau de l’enfance et le tableau de l’usine
par Karl Marx ». À la vérité, c’est
Dickens qui influence Marx. Lorsque le grand
philosophe vit à Londres, à partir des années
1850, il est notamment marqué par la terrible
description que Dickens fait de la vie de
la classe ouvrière de Manchester (la ville
de l’industrie du charbon) dans Les Temps
difficiles, son roman le plus engagé.
Oliver Twist ne décrit pas la condition ouvrière,
mais il met en lumière la misère qui est
une conséquence de l’industrialisation.
Il est incontournable dans la littérature
occidentale dans la mesure où c’est un
roman pionnier de la critique sociale. À
travers ce récit, Dickens montre comment
la société traite ses membres les plus vulnérables,
en particulier les enfants. Et le fait que
le protagoniste du roman soit un enfant jouera
un rôle crucial dans la sensibilisation du
public aux problèmes sociaux de l'époque.
Sur la forme, l’édition complète représente
un pavé de plus de 700 pages (c’est pourquoi
les éditeurs ont créé une édition abrégée
pour les jeunes lecteurs). C’est si long
parce que le livre rassemble en réalité
32 feuilletons publiés dans une revue sur
plus de deux ans (un éditeur de roman a plutôt
intérêt à réduire le nombre de pages pour
réduire ses coûts, tandis qu’un éditeur
de revue a plutôt intérêt à faire durer
l’histoire). Concernant la prose, Dickens
écrit des phrases complexes, souvent longues,
qui peuvent contenir plusieurs propositions.
Son style littéraire produit de belles images,
avec une tendance à l'hyperbole et à la
satire, mais il est compliqué pour un lecteur
de 2023.
Je vous résume rapidement l’histoire.
Oliver naît orphelin dans un hospice. Il
a faim en permanence et il est victime de
traitements cruels. Après avoir osé demander
plus de nourriture — ce qui passe pour un
acte de rébellion — il devient apprenti
chez un croque-mort. Ne supportant pas une
insulte envers sa mère, Oliver s'enfuit vers
Londres. Là, il rencontre un pickpocket qui
l'introduit à Fagin, un vieil homme à la
tête d'une bande de jeunes voleurs.
Petite précision : le personnage de Fagin
a valu à Dickens d’être accusé d’antisémitisme
parce qu’il précise que Fagin est Juif
et qu’il appelle à de nombreuses reprises
« le Juif ». Si Dickens s’est défendu
en disant que les managers de pickpockets
qu’il connaissait étaient effectivement
juifs, le personnage de Fagin et la manière
dont Dickens le présente — cela crée un
archétype qui risque malheureusement de nourrir
l’antisémitisme.
Je reprends l’histoire.
À Londres, Oliver bascule rapidement dans
le monde du crime. Accusé à tort de vol,
il est sauvé par un témoignage et adopté
par la victime, M. Brownlow. Cependant, Fagin
et ses complices craignent qu'Oliver ne les
trahisse — donc ils le kidnappent. Ensuite
forcé de participer à un cambriolage, Oliver
est blessé dans l'opération. Il est recueilli
et soigné par les victimes qu’il voulait
prévenir, une dame et sa nièce Rose.
Alors qu'Oliver est heureux avec ces femmes,
Fagin, aidé d’un mystérieux partenaire
dénommé Monks, continue de le traquer. Mais
Nancy, une complice de Fagin, trahit ce dernier
en révélant à Rose que Monks est le demi-frère
d'Oliver, et qu’il cherche à s'emparer
de son héritage. Cette trahison coûtera
la vie à Nancy.
La vérité éclate : Monks, le complice de
Fagin et demi-frère d'Oliver, admet avoir
voulu ruiner Oliver pour garder son héritage.
L’autre complice de Fagin qui a assassiné
Nancy se tue accidentellement dans sa fuite.
Fagin, lui, est arrêté et exécuté. La
paix revient : Oliver, l’homme qui l’a
adopté et les femmes qui l’ont accueilli
vivent heureux dans un village paisible en
Angleterre.
Que retenir de l’influence de ce roman dans
la littérature et la culture occidentales
?
La dimension la plus importante de cette influence
est la sensibilisation à la misère du siècle.
Charles Dickens choisit de le faire à travers
le prisme de l’enfance parce qu’il a lui-même
passé une année traumatisante, à 12 ans,
en tant qu’ouvrier dans une manufacture
de cirage. Son choix aura deux effets notables.
Comme je l’ai déjà dit, les malheurs d’un
enfant sensibilisent plus efficacement le
public. Ensuite, suivre le destin d’un enfant
depuis sa naissance impose l’idée que c’est
l’influence continue de la société, et
non pas le caractère inné de l’individu,
qui engendre la misère, le vice et le crime.
Troublés par cette idée, certains critiques
malhonnêtes iront jusqu’à reprocher à
Dickens de faire l’apologie de la délinquance.
Une autre dimension de l’influence de ce
roman est le format de feuilleton. Le grand
succès d’Oliver Twist a contribué à légitimer
ce format. En même temps qu’il a démocratisé
la littérature, ce format a fait évoluer
la structure narrative vers des formes et
des techniques qui permettent de conserver
l’intérêt du lecteur tout au long de l’histoire.
Le romancier doit par exemple maîtriser l’art
du suspense et des rebondissements inattendus.
Enfin, Oliver Twist est devenu un personnage
mythique dans la culture britannique, et plus
généralement occidentale. Dans l’imaginaire
collectif, il est l’archétype de l’enfant
vulnérable dans un monde adulte impitoyable.
Son histoire sera adaptée en de nombreuses
pièces de théâtre, films, séries télévisées,
et comédies musicales. La plus fameuse adaptation
est la comédie musicale du début des années
60, Oliver! (avec un point d’exclamation),
qui est jouée à Londres, puis à Broadway
(le célèbre théâtre de New York), avant
de devenir en 1968 un film qui décrochera
6 oscars, dont celui du meilleur film.
6ème référence : Crime et Châtiment (1866),
Fiodor Dostoïevski
J’ai peu de temps pour progresser en russe,
donc j’écoute souvent des podcasts en promenant
mon chien. Hier après-midi, par exemple,
j’écoutais une discussion entre deux jeunes
profs de russe, l’un vivant à Saint-Pétersbourg,
l’autre à Barcelone. Ils parlent de leurs
villes respectives, et à un moment, la prof
établie à Barcelone commente le climat déprimant
de Saint-Pétersbourg en disant : « c’est
une ville qui donne envie de tuer une vieille
dame ». C’est une référence à ce roman,
Crime et Châtiment, de Dostoïevski. Il a
tant imprégné l’imaginaire national russe
qu’il est une référence culturelle ordinaire
dans la conversation de deux jeunes Russes
des années 2020.
Mais la célébrité de ce livre dépasse
largement la Russie. C’est un des plus grands
romans de tous les temps. Il a influencé
des films américains (comme Match Point de
Woody Allen) et il est mentionné sur les
réseaux sociaux. Précisément parlant, il
passe pour le roman psychologique — ou philosophique,
si on veut — le plus profond du XIXe siècle.
Beaucoup d’écrivains — dont par exemple
Freud, Nabokov, ou René Girard — ont analysé
ce roman. Jordan Peterson, le psychologue
controversé qui est actuellement l’intellectuel
le plus populaire sur internet en Occident,
mentionne souvent Crime et Châtiment.
Mais la gloire de Dostoïevski n’est pas
que posthume. Il a 45 ans lorsque ce roman
fait de lui un écrivain star, comparé aux
plus grands noms de la littérature russe.
Les thèmes de Crime et Châtiment agitent
l’opinion publique. Certes, la masse des
lecteurs n’en saisit pas le message profond.
Mais elle aime beaucoup le mélange de roman
policier, d’histoire sentimentale et de
thèse philosophique qu’elle trouve dans
ce roman.
Sur la forme, il y en a pour entre 500 et
700 pages selon les éditions — donc ça
ne sera pas l’histoire d’une soirée au
coin du feu. Dostoïevski a un style plutôt
clair dans les traductions françaises, avec
des structures de phrase et un vocabulaire
plutôt simples (en tout cas compréhensibles
pour un lecteur de 2023). Après, les plongées
dans les dilemmes moraux des personnages rendent
le roman pas toujours facile à lire.
Maintenant, je vous résume rapidement l’histoire.
Raskolnikov, un jeune homme pauvre de Saint-Pétersbourg,
est tourmenté par une idée fixe : certains
individus « extraordinaires » peuvent se
libérer de la morale pour le bien supérieur
de la société. Se persuadant qu’il appartient
à cette élite, Raskolnikov assassine sa
logeuse, une vieille usurière. Il vole ses
biens ; puis tue également la demi-sœur
de la logeuse lorsqu’elle découvre le corps
de celle-ci. Le fait que Raskolnikov soit
un ancien étudiant — il a interrompu ses
études faute d’argent— cela déplaît
aux étudiants russes de l’époque, qui
ont l’impression d’être dépeints comme
des criminels en puissance.
Je reviens à l’histoire.
Rongé par la culpabilité, Raskolnikov joue
un jeu dangereux avec le commissaire en charge
de trouver le meurtrier. Leur rapport et l’avancée
progressive de l’enquête seront un des
ingrédients du succès immédiat du livre
(plus que les qualités profondes qui en feront
un chef-d’œuvre de la littérature mondiale,
d’ailleurs).
Alors que l’enquête avance, Raskolnikov
rencontre une famille en difficulté, dont
la fille Sonya est une jeune prostituée (les
jeunes femmes réduites à la prostitution
pour survivre sont un aspect dérangeant de
la misère des grandes villes que Dostoïevski
met en évidence dans ce roman). Cette jeune
prostituée, Sonya, devient un soutien émotionnel
pour Raskolnikov. Elle l'encourage à trouver
le réconfort dans la foi et à se confesser.
L’intrigue avance lorsqu’un homme possédant
des informations sur le crime de Raskolnikov
tente de manipuler la situation à son avantage.
Mais ce potentiel délateur finit par se suicider.
Cet événement accentue la pression sur Raskolnikov.
Poussé par Sonya, Raskolnikov se rend finalement
à la police. Il est condamné à l'exil en
Sibérie. Sonya le suit et reste à ses côtés
(la femme russe qui accompagne son homme au
bagne est une image populaire souvent convoquée
pour illustrer la légendaire fidélité des
femmes russes). À la fin du roman, Raskolnikov
trouve la rédemption grâce à l'amour et
au soutien de Sonya.
Comment expliquer l’importance et l’influence
de Crime et châtiment ?
En premier lieu, il popularise le genre du
roman psychologique. Dostoïevski y explore
avec une profondeur inégalée les méandres
de l'esprit humain, plongeant dans les tourments
intérieurs de Raskolnikov après son crime.
Au lieu de se concentrer principalement sur
l'action extérieure, Dostoïevski attire
l’attention du lecteur sur les conflits
émotionnels et la complexité des dilemmes
moraux. Ce choix inspirera d’autres romanciers,
parmi lesquels Marcel Proust ou James Joyce.
Parler de la vie intérieure présentera un
avantage décisif au XXe siècle : cela permet
au roman de s’adapter à la concurrence
du cinéma, qui décrit mieux les personnages
et les situations.
Deuxième dimension de l’influence de Crime
et châtiment, il popularise le thème de
la critique du nihilisme, qu’on peut définir
comme la doctrine d’après laquelle il n’existe
aucune vérité morale. De manière évidente,
l’acte de Raskolnikiv et sa descente aux
enfers psychologique montrent que le nihilisme
n’est bon ni pour la société ni pour l’individu.
Certains disent que ce roman est « du Nietzche
avant l’heure », parce qu’il traite déjà
de la révolution des mentalités que le philosophe
ramassera dans la formule « Dieu est mort
» (formule qui signifie que le déclin des
croyances religieuses risque de faire disparaître
les valeurs de la civilisation). D’ailleurs,
Nietzsche découvrira Dostoïevski sur le
tard et s’émerveillera de la proximité
de leurs idées.
Enfin, dernière dimension essentielle de
l’influence de Crime et châtiment, il symbolise
un peu l’âme russe. À travers ce roman,
les Occidentaux perçoivent la Russie comme
une nation introspective, tourmentée, et
profondément philosophique.
7ème référence : Guerre et Paix (1867),
Léon Tolstoï
J’ai lu ce roman dans une chambre d’hôtel
lors de la crise de 2008. Comme je faisais
ma deuxième année d’école de commerce
à Londres, j’avais dû trouver un stage
dans les environs. Et étant donné le marasme
économique et mon désintérêt pour mes
études, je me suis contenté d’un stage
de complaisance obtenu grâce au propriétaire
de la chambre d’étudiant que j’avais
occupée pendant ma prépa. L’entreprise
où j’ai débarqué, à deux heures de train
de ma colocation londonienne, n’avait absolument
aucun travail à me confier. Ainsi, les deux
premières semaines, je rentrais tôt dans
ma chambre d’hôtel, et je me plongeais
dans Guerre et Paix de Tolstoï.
Comme Crime et châtiment de Dostoïevski,
Guerre et Paix est un des plus grands romans
de la littérature mondiale. Pour faire simple,
c’est la plus célèbre fresque historique
du genre romanesque. Les premiers chapitres
parus dans la presse avaient été critiqués,
mais la sortie du livre consacre immédiatement
Tolstoï — qui était déjà un écrivain
à succès — comme un géant de la littérature
russe. Les lecteurs dévalisent les librairies,
offrent le roman à leurs amis, s’écrivent
d’un bout à l’autre de la Russie pour
échanger leurs opinions sur les héros. Tous
les écrivains russes de l’époque ont conscience
qu’un événement de première importance
vient de se produire dans leur univers.
Pour l’anecdote, Tolstoï a repris le titre
d’un essai du philosophe anarchiste français
Proudhon paru quelques années plus tôt.
Dans cet essai, Proudhon parle du sens de
la guerre pour l’organisation sociale — et
Tolstoï fait un peu la même chose, mais
sous la forme d’un roman.
Avec deux tomes de 1000 pages, Guerre et Paix
est un des plus grands romans historiques
au sens propre. Le projet de Tolstoï semblait
si vaste et si ambitieux lorsqu’il a commencé
que sa femme s’attendait à ce qu’il abandonne
rapidement. Mais il en est venu à bout en
six ans. C’est si long qu’il y a forcément
des erreurs malgré les innombrables relectures
(par exemple, le même médaillon est en argent
dans une scène, en or dans une autre) — mais
les lecteurs ne s’en aperçoivent pas tant
l’art du conteur de Tolstoï est entraînant.
Son style est plutôt clair. Il a tendance
à allonger les phrases et à sophistiquer
la structure, mais elles restent compréhensibles.
Le vocabulaire est riche — Tolstoï aime
bien faire des observations précises — mais
le vocabulaire n’est pas inutilement compliqué.
Tolstoï adapte les dialogues à la personnalité
et à la condition sociale des personnages.
Il prend le temps de décrire les paysages,
les intérieurs, et même les psychologies
des personnages.
Je vous résume maintenant l’histoire.
Par mesure de simplicité, je centre mon résumé
sur le héros le plus central et complexe
du roman, Pierre Bézoukhov, dont l'évolution
personnelle sert de fil rouge à l'intrigue.
En 1805 (le titre initial du roman était
d’ailleurs « L’Année 1805 ») — cette
année-là, la Russie est en guerre contre
la France de Napoléon. Pierre Bézoukhov,
un jeune homme maladroit mais intelligent,
fait son entrée dans la haute société de
Saint-Pétersbourg. Il devient l'un des hommes
les plus riches de Russie en héritant de
son père. Malgré cette fortune, sa vie est
chaotique. En particulier, il épouse une
femme qui ne l'aime pas, et qui s'avère infidèle.
Pierre se tourne vers les francs-maçons et
tente sans succès de réformer ses domaines
pour améliorer la vie de ses paysans (c’est
un thème cher à Tolstoï). La Russie signe
un traité de paix temporaire avec la France.
La vie de Pierre se complique avec les rumeurs
d'infidélité de sa femme, qui le poussent
à un duel et à la séparation.
La guerre reprend quelques années plus tard.
Pierre est pris dans la tourmente en dépit
de son manque d'expérience militaire. Il
finit par être capturé par les soldats de
Napoléon (que Pierre projetait d’assassiner)
lors de l'invasion de Moscou. Cette captivité
s'avère être une période de transformation
profonde. Dans le camp, il rencontre un paysan
simple qui lui fait voir la vie et la foi
en Dieu sous un jour nouveau.
Libéré lors de la retraite française, Pierre
retourne en Russie. Il découvre que sa femme
est morte, ce qui le libère de son mariage
malheureux. Devenu un homme nouveau grâce
aux épreuves traversées, il trouve enfin
l'amour véritable et épouse Natacha qui,
comme lui, a connu des épreuves dont elle
est ressortie plus forte. Ils trouvent un
bonheur simple mais profond en fondant une
famille (ce qui est la vision du bonheur de
Tolstoï).
Le roman se conclut par une méditation sur
le rôle des individus dans le grand cours
de l'Histoire. La thèse de Tolstoï est que
le grand homme est une illusion. « Dans les
faits historiques, écrit-il, les soi-disant
grands hommes ne sont que des étiquettes
qui servent à désigner ces faits mais n’ont
pas plus de rapport avec eux que des étiquettes.
» Image drôle, il compare également Napoléon
à un enfant qui tient des rubans fixés à
l’intérieur d’une voiture et qui s’imagine
que c’est lui qui conduit les chevaux.
Comment expliquer l’importance et l’influence
de Guerre et Paix ?
En premier lieu, ce roman est un modèle narratif.
Il a établi un nouveau standard en matière
de narration épique. L’approche est multidimensionnelle
: Tolstoï a réussi à intégrer des éléments
historiques, des drames humains, des théories
philosophiques et militaires dans une seule
œuvre, tout en conservant une cohérence
et une profondeur. Par crainte d’ennuyer
le lecteur, il a supprimé une bonne partie
des développements théoriques ; mais il
les a finalement remis lors du remaniement
suivant.
En deuxième lieu, ce roman a un intérêt
historique : il raconte les guerres napoléoniennes
du point de vue de la Russie. Tolstoï s’était
énormément documenté afin d’être capable
de donner une image fidèle des événements.
De ma lecture, je garde notamment en souvenir
la patience et la sagesse militaire du général
russe victorieux Koutouzov, qui incarne la
capacité à tirer profit des forces qui façonnent
l’histoire, par opposition à Napoléon,
soumis à l’illusion de la volonté individuelle.
Enfin, Guerre et Paix renouvelle également
la tradition du roman philosophique. Il sert
de véhicule aux idées philosophiques de
Tolstoï (qui seront influentes en Occident
au XXe siècle). L’histoire est une toile
de fond pour explorer des questions philosophiques
profondes, telles que le bien et le mal, le
libre arbitre, et la complexité des motivations
humaines. En particulier, le destin de Pierre
Bézoukhov — le héros sur lequel j’ai
centré mon résumé — son destin incarne
l’idée que le mode de vie de Tolstoï,
un bonheur familial en retrait de l’agitation
sociale, est la solution à la quête de sens
de l’homme spirituel qui a atteint la maturité
psychologique. Les digressions philosophiques
de Tolstoï seront parodiées par Woody Allen
dans un film de 1975 intitulé Guerre et Amour.
Petite interruption parce que je me dis que
si vous aimez l’esprit de cette vidéo — à
savoir découvrir des choses intéressantes
en allant à l’essentiel et sans se prendre
la tête — alors vous aimerez probablement
mon programme Culture Express.
C’est un programme méthodique pour devenir
facilement une personne cultivée en seulement
quelques mois.
Il couvre tous les domaines de la culture
générale : vous maîtriserez les connaissances
essentielles sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France, en économie,
en science politique, en psychologie, en science,
en littérature, en art, en religion, et en
philosophie.
Vous ne serez plus jamais à court de choses
à dire et vous gagnerez la confiance nécessaire
pour briller en toutes circonstances.
Vous pouvez en savoir plus en cliquant sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore en tapant directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Mais je pense que la meilleure façon de vous
donner une idée du programme est d’écouter
ce que les membres ont à en dire.
Valentine, qui reconnaît l’énorme quantité
de travail que ce programme a représenté
pour moi, dit que « c’est une véritable
mine d’or [...] L’essentiel est là, tout
est simple, pratique, très bien expliqué,
concentré, il n’y a plus qu’à recopier
et à apprendre. Ce travail est vraiment formidable
et passionnant. »
Maxence m’écrit directement dans les commentaires
en-dessous d’une vidéo du programme : « Ta
formation est vraiment remarquable. J'étais
un peu dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas, c'est un vrai travail
de synthèse que tu nous proposes et le format
vidéo est très adapté pour moi qui ai une
mémoire essentiellement auditive. Le choix
des thèmes et des chapitres est pertinent
et je trouve que tu as trouvé la dose d'approfondissement
parfaite ; à la fois précis mais sans fioritures
! »
Vincent, lui, fait carrément ma pub : « J’ai
d’ailleurs recommandé votre formation à
ma sœur qui travaille comme diplomate [...]. La
semaine dernière, elle a déjà eu l’occasion
de mettre à profit, dans ses discussions,
les connaissances que vous avez diffusées.
»
Vous verrez d’autres témoignages comme
ceux-ci dans les commentaires si vous rejoignez
le programme. Et si vous vous inscrivez, vous
bénéficiez d'une garantie résultats : une
fois que vous aurez terminé le programme,
je vous rembourserai intégralement si vous
estimez que vous n’avez pas acquis une solide
culture générale.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus, cliquez sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore tapez directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Plus de 800 membres ont déjà tiré parti
de ce programme, et je serais ravi qu’il
en soit de même pour vous.
8ème référence : Le Portrait de Dorian
Gray (1890), Oscar Wilde
André Gide, qui est, après Proust, le deuxième
géant de la littérature française du début
du XXe siècle — Gide raconte dans ses souvenirs
d’Oscar Wilde que ce dernier lui aurait
confié avoir écrit ce roman, Le Portrait
de Dorian Gray, par défi, en seulement quelques
jours, parce qu’un de ses amis l’avait
déclaré incapable d’écrire des romans
(Oscar Wilde était en effet un des dramaturges
les plus en vue de Londres avant de se mettre
à écrire Le Portrait de Dorian Gray, qui
sera effectivement son unique roman). Mais
cette confidence de Wilde à Gide est soit
une plaisanterie, soit une légende, parce
qu’Oscar Wilde a en réalité eu besoin
de 9 mois pour remettre son manuscrit à l’éditeur.
Le Portrait de Dorian Gray est incontournable
dans la littérature occidentale parce qu’il
est le roman de référence sur le thème
de la dualité de la personnalité. Il symbolise
notamment la tension entre l’apparence et
la réalité. Il y a l’image lisse que chacun
donne à voir aux autres ; et puis il y a
la réalité cachée, la face sombre derrière
cette image, ce que chacun est dans son intimité
la plus secrète. Le Portrait de Dorian Gray
est également un roman de référence sur
le thème de la corruption morale de l’élite
sociale oisive.
Concernant la forme, il y en a pour entre
250 et 300 pages selon les éditions, donc
cela se lit plutôt rapidement. La prose d’Oscar
Wilde est globalement accessible. L’expression
est éloquente et littéraire par rapport
à la langue ordinaire (on ressent l’élitisme
artistique de l’auteur). Si les phrases
sont en général plutôt longues, l’habileté
de la syntaxe et de la ponctuation permet
de les comprendre. Ce sont surtout les références
culturelles qui compliquent la tâche du lecteur.
Enfin, on retrouve le talent d’Oscar Wilde
pour jouer avec les mots. Cela donne des remarques
spirituelles et des formules mémorables (une
des plus connues étant « Le seul moyen de
se délivrer d'une tentation, c'est d'y céder
»). Le sens de la formule d’Oscar Wilde
se manifeste à l’extrême dans la préface
du roman, qui ressemble à une compilation
d’aphorismes.
Je passe au résumé de l’histoire.
Dorian Gray est un beau jeune homme. Il est
peint par un artiste nommé Basil. Lors de
la séance, Dorian rencontre un ami de Basil,
Lord Henry, qui lui parle de l'importance
de la jeunesse et de la beauté. Subjugué,
Dorian exprime le souhait que ce soit son
portrait qui vieillisse à sa place. Il passe
sans le savoir un pacte faustien : Dorian
vend son âme afin de préserver à jamais
son apparence. Dorian se rapproche de Lord
Henry, l’ami du peintre, et le peintre pressent
l’influence néfaste de Lord Henry sur Dorian.
Le pouvoir malsain du portrait se révèle
plus tard. Dorian tombe amoureux d’une actrice
talentueuse nommée Sybil. Tout change lorsque
celle-ci, éperdument amoureuse, joue mal
lors d'une représentation. Dorian la rejette
cruellement. Or, de retour chez lui, il remarque
que son portrait a changé : il affiche désormais
une expression méprisante. Le lendemain,
Dorian se sent coupable et veut se réconcilier
avec Sibyl. Mais Lord Henry — l’ami du
peintre, l’homme qui a une influence néfaste
sur Dorian — Lord Henry apprend à Dorian
que l’actrice, Sibyl, s'est suicidée. Dorian
est d'abord perturbé ; puis Henry le persuade
de voir ce drame comme une œuvre d'art. Dorian
accepte cette perspective immorale et remarque
que son portrait porte désormais la culpabilité
à sa place.
Les années passent sans affecter la jeunesse
et la beauté de Dorian, qui est populaire
dans les milieux mondains. En revanche, son
portrait est de plus en plus monstrueux. Chaque
acte immoral commis par Dorian rend le portrait
un peu plus laid. Paranoïaque à l'idée
que son secret puisse être découvert, Dorian
cache le portrait dans son grenier. Un soir,
le peintre Basil rend visite à Dorian et
l’interroge à propos des rumeurs disant
qu’il mène une vie de débauche. Dorian
lui montre alors le portrait. Horrifié, Basil
exhorte Dorian à chercher le pardon pour
ses péchés. Enragé, Dorian tue Basil. Il
fait ensuite disparaître le corps avec l'aide
d'un chimiste qu'il fait chanter.
Le désir de changement de Dorian naît plus
tard. James, le frère de Sibyl, l’actrice
qui s’est suicidée à cause de Dorian,
veut venger sa sœur. Caché dans la propriété
de Dorian, il est accidentellement tué par
un chasseur. Rongé de culpabillité, Dorian
décide alors de changer. Ainsi, il refuse
de profiter d’une jeune femme tombée amoureuse
de lui. Mais contrairement à ses attentes,
le portrait évolue encore en mal : une expression
hypocrite s'y est ajoutée. Désespéré,
Dorian détruit son portrait avec le couteau
qui avait servi à tuer Basil, l’auteur
du portrait. Ses serviteurs le retrouvent
mort, le couteau planté dans la poitrine.
Son visage juvénile a disparu ; seuls les
bijoux à ses doigts permettent de l’identifier.
Comment expliquer l’influence de ce roman
dans la littérature et la culture occidentales
?
En premier lieu, il est devenu une œuvre
emblématique de ce qu’on appelle la « littérature
fin-de-siècle ». Cette expression regroupe
les productions de certains auteurs du dernier
tiers du XIXe siècle. Influencés par le
pessimisme du philosophe Schopenhauer, ils
cultivent un élitisme artistique à l’écart
de la société, qu’ils méprisent.
Ensuite, Le Portrait de Dorian Gray est un
des plus célèbres symboles de la dualité
humaine dans la culture occidentale. Le destin
du protagoniste illustre la tension entre
l’apparence, qui est le mal, et la réalité,
qui est le bien. C’est aussi une manière
de dénoncer l’hypocrisie de la morale sociale,
laquelle ne se soucie que des apparences.
Le succès du roman d’Oscar Wilde tient
en partie au pouvoir de fascination universel
et intemporel de ce thème de la dualité
humaine. Le personnage de Dorian Gray et l'intrigue
du roman ont atteint un statut quasi-mythique
dans la culture occidentale. Ils inspirent
les sciences humaines et sont régulièrement
adaptés dans la culture populaire (quatre
films différents — dont un film d’horreur
— rien que depuis les années 2000).
9ème référence : La Faim (1890), Knut Hamsun
En 1929, Knut Hamsun est une star internationale
: son 70ème anniversaire est donc célébré
dans le monde entier. Il a décroché le Prix
Nobel de littérature neuf ans plus tôt,
en 1920. Les plus grands noms de la littérature
— par exemple Franz Kafka, André Gide,
ou Henry Miller — les plus grands auteurs
le lisent et l’estiment comme un des meilleurs,
sinon le meilleur auteur vivant. Mais voilà,
Knut Hamsun crame complètement sa réputation
lors de la Seconde Guerre mondiale. Il fait
ce que la postérité ne pourra pas lui pardonner
: il soutient ouvertement les nazis. Il va
même bien plus loin : il rencontre personnellement
Hitler en 1943, et il offre même sa médaille
du prix Nobel à Joseph Goebbels, le chef
de la propagande nazie. Knut Hamsun est plus
qu’un simple partisan ; il est un véritable
fan dont l’admiration n’est pas affectée
par la tournure des événements. Une semaine
après la mort d’Hitler, en 1945, Hamsun
écrit dans le deuxième quotidien de Norvège
que le führer était, je cite, « un guerrier
pour l’humanité ».
Pas étonnant, du coup, que les manuels minimisent,
voire dissimulent son influence dans la littérature
occidentale. Mais ce roman, La Faim, ne peut
pas être oublié. Les gens qui ont entendu
parler de Knut Hamsun en savent d’ordinaire
deux choses : il a écrit La Faim et il a
rencontré Hitler. Pourquoi ce roman, écrit
en 1890, plus de 50 ans avant la rencontre
avec le dictateur nazi, est-il incontournable
? Parce qu’il représente la transition
entre le réalisme, le modèle dominant de
la littérature du XIXe siècle, et l’exploration
de la subjectivité, qui est la tendance dominante
de la littérature du XXe siècle (et dont
le roman emblématique est bien sûr À la
recherche du temps perdu de Proust). Pour
simplifier, vous pouvez retenir que ce roman
représente la transition entre le modèle
d’écriture dominant de la littérature
du XIXe siècle et le modèle d’écriture
dominant de la littérature du XXe siècle.
Concernant la forme, La Faim est un livre
qui fait entre 250 et 300 pages selon les
éditions. Il se lit plutôt facilement. La
longueur des paragraphes et des phrases varie.
La syntaxe et le vocabulaire sont simples
: c’est un style dépouillé qui a notamment
inspiré Hemingway. Le fait que Hamsun écrive
à la première personne pour raconter avec
précision ce qu’il fait et ce qu’il ressent
— cela permet au lecteur de se lier émotionnellement
au narrateur. En conclusion, ce roman est
vraiment accessible.
La seule chose qui rend la lecture pénible,
c’est le sujet. En effet, Knut Hamsun raconte
le lamentable spectacle, probablement autobiographique,
d’un homme attiré par l’abîme psychologique
de la faim. Comme il a été lui-même longtemps
pauvre et soumis aux privations, il brosse
avec la précision de l’expérience les
troubles intellectuels et les déformations
morales qu’entraîne une inanition prolongée.
Si le protagoniste a faim, c’est tout d’abord
parce qu’il est pauvre. Il est pris dans
une course permanente à l’argent où il
ne semble jamais pouvoir rattraper pour de
bon son retard. Ne tirant ses maigres revenus
que des articles — pour la plupart refusés
— qu’il compose pour divers journaux ainsi
que des biens qu’il met en gage, il lui
arrive de passer jusqu’à trois jours sans
se nourrir, au point où la faim devient tyrannique.
Le sort s’acharne sur lui dans ces périodes
critiques : les personnes susceptibles de
l’aider sont toutes absentes, ou il arrive
toujours trop tard ; les ridicules objets
qu’il propose en gage (des boutons, une
couverture) sont tous refusés. Knut Hamsun
met en lumière le cercle vicieux de la pauvreté
: le froid des nuits affaiblit un peu plus
son personnage, qui n’a pas assez d’argent
pour acheter les bougies nécessaires à la
rédaction de son article. Cette condition
s’accompagne toutefois d’une forme de
lucidité qui pourrait être liée à la faim
: « le pauvre intelligent, écrit Hamsun,
était un observateur bien plus fin que le
riche intelligent ».
Mais fondamentalement, la faim perturbe le
fonctionnement de l’esprit. Le héros de
Hamsun est particulièrement attentif aux
effets mentaux et intellectuels de sa sous-alimentation.
Celle-ci entraîne tout d’abord des symptômes
de surface : fatigue, déprime, sautes d’humeur,
obsession de la nourriture, nausées, maux
de tête, vomissements, troubles du sommeil,
sensation proche de l’ivresse, ou profond
détachement. Le pauvre journaliste remarque
qu’un jeûne d’une période assez longue
(plusieurs jours) laisse une sorte de « vide
» dans son cerveau. C’est alors que les
symptômes deviennent mentaux et spirituels.
Constamment obsédé par la nourriture, le
jeune homme peine à se concentrer pour travailler
(j’avais le même problème lorsque j’ai
fait un jeûne de 3 jours). Son esprit divague
et n’est plus capable que d’associer les
idées. Ses articles sont trop fiévreux et
violents. En effet, la faim décuple les errements
de son esprit, l’entraînant par exemple
dans un délire d’invention de mots. Il
ne parvient même plus à effectuer des opérations
mentales basiques, comme un simple calcul
de fractions pour son loyer, et il commet
des erreurs grossières, par exemple sur la
date d’une lettre de motivation.
Autre problème, la faim affaiblit le sens
moral. En temps normal, le protagoniste est
profondément soucieux de la dimension morale
de ses actes. Par exemple, il tient un compte
précis de ses diverses dettes, et il les
règle en priorité dès que ses finances
le lui permettent. Son désir de dissimuler
sa misère le conduit même à pratiquer la
charité : il sacrifie donc volontiers son
maigre confort de court terme pour venir en
aide à des individus d’un niveau de pauvreté
probablement pourtant comparable au sien.
Mais la faim met à mal cette droiture en
apparence inflexible : elle soumet le héros
à d’intenses changements d’humeur, le
faisant passer de la dépression à la folie.
Il est finalement contraint d’abandonner
sa rigueur morale. La sensation de la faim
est telle qu’il en vient à mendier ; à
mettre en gage des objets qui ne lui appartiennent
pas (la couverture de sa logeuse) ; et même
à demander à un caissier de se servir dans
la caisse pour lui faire un prêt.
Que retenir de l’influence de ce roman dans
la littérature et la culture occidentales
?
La dimension la plus importante de cette influence
est, comme je l’ai dit au début, que La
Faim introduit le modèle de la fiction littéraire
du XXe siècle. L’écrivain Isaac Bashevis
Singer, qui a écrit une préface, dit carrément
que ce roman fait de Hamsun, je cite « le
père de l'école moderne de la littérature
». L’exploration de la subjectivité par
le monologue intérieur, mais aussi le caractère
fragmentaire de la prose, et l’usage des
flash-back — ces ingrédients inspireront
fortement les romanciers du XXe siècle.
Une autre dimension de l’influence de ce
roman est qu’il popularise, comme l’a
fait Crime et châtiment une génération
plus tôt, le genre du roman psychologique.
Hamsun était d’ailleurs très inspiré
par Dostoïevski, et on l’appelait « le
Dostoïevski du Nord » (André Gide estimait
même que Hamsun était un meilleur écrivain
que Dostoïevski).
Sur le plan culturel, plus largement, ce roman
préfigure l’existentialisme qui deviendra
une mode intellectuelle au début des Trente
Glorieuses. Le thème de la faim et de ses
effets psychologiques inspire en effet l’idée
que la condition humaine est un mélange d’aliénation
et d’absurdité. On retrouvera également
cette vision de l’existence chez Kafka.
Enfin, ce roman a aujourd’hui dans la culture
occidentale le statut de « chef-d’œuvre
d’un auteur maudit ». C’est un peu comme
Voyage au bout de la nuit de Céline, mais
en bien pire. Très embarrassées par le nazisme
de leur génie national, les autorités norvégiennes
de l’après-guerre prétendent qu’il est
fou, et le baladent d’un asile à l’autre.
Mais son tout dernier livre, où il raconte
cette période, prouve qu’il n’était
pas fou.
10ème référence : Ulysse (1918), James
Joyce
Six ans après la parution de ce roman, James
Joyce écrit à sa mécène, une riche héritière
féministe, que le 16 juin, un groupe de personnes
célèbrent en lui envoyant des fleurs ce
qu’ils appellent « le Bloomsday » en référence
au personnage de ce roman, Leopold Bloom.
Trente ans plus tard, en 1954, un groupe d’admirateurs
du romancier fait passer la célébration
au niveau supérieur en organisant un pèlerinage
d’une journée dans Dublin, la capitale
irlandaise, en suivant l’itinéraire décrit
dans ce roman. Depuis lors, le Bloomsday est
même devenu une des plus importantes fêtes
irlandaises. Chaque année, le 16 juin, des
admirateurs de Joyce s’habillent à la mode
de son époque et parcourent Dublin en citant
des passages de ce roman.
Ulysse est un roman incontournable parce que
c’est très certainement le plus grand roman
de langue anglaise du XXe siècle (il arrive
souvent premier dans les classements). Il
est un peu à la littérature anglophone ce
qu’À la recherche du temps perdu de Proust
(écrit quelques années plus tôt) est à
la littérature française, c’est-à-dire
le modèle emblématique de la nouvelle orientation
du genre romanesque au XXe siècle.
Ulysse est bien moins long qu’À la recherche
du temps perdu, mais il faudra quand même
faire un effort pour faire partie de l’infime
minorité des gens qui l’ont lu en entier,
car il y en a pour 700-800 pages selon les
éditions. Et ce n’est pas la seule difficulté.
En effet, Ulysse est aussi célèbre pour
le fait que c’est un des chefs-d'œuvre
les plus difficiles à lire de toute la littérature
occidentale. À en croire Joyce lui-même,
l’obscurité de sa prose est en partie intentionnelle
: c’est un moyen de fasciner le public.
« J'ai inséré tellement d'énigmes et de
casse-tête, dira-t-il, que cela occupera
les professeurs pendant des siècles à débattre
de ce que je voulais dire, et c'est la seule
manière de garantir l’immortalité de ce
livre ».
Concernant la forme, la prose de Joyce est
bien compliquée. La longueur des phrases
n’est pas problématique, mais le vocabulaire
est déroutant par son originalité et sa
technicité. Les jeux de mots et les références
culturelles compliquent un peu plus la tâche
du lecteur. Si la variété des styles apporte
du dynamisme, elle est également déroutante
(le style change à chaque partie du livre).
La dernière partie du roman est même un
texte expérimental de plusieurs dizaines
de pages : ce texte n’est presque pas subdivisé
en paragraphes afin de refléter la continuité
d’un monologue intérieur (celui de la femme
du protagoniste). C’est original, mais ce
n’est pas fait pour le plaisir de la lecture.
D’un point de vue global, Joyce fait l’inverse
de ce que préconisent les manuels d’écriture
: il cultive l’ambiguïté. En laissant
la place à de multiples interprétations,
il offre, d’un côté, une expérience spéciale
au lecteur ; mais de l’autre côté, il
prend le risque de le frustrer. Contrairement
à Stendhal qui écrivait pour être toujours
lu par les lecteurs des siècles suivants,
Joyce s’est condamné — à mon humble
avis — à n’être lu que par les experts
de la littérature les plus motivés.
Ce livre est si compliqué qu’un Américain,
prof de lettres dans un prestigieux lycée
privé, a carrément écrit un guide pour
comprendre le roman. Ce guide est intitulé
The Guide to James Joyce's Ulysses (en français,
« Le guide pour comprendre l’Ulysse de
James Joyce »). En fait, Ulysse est si important
dans la littérature anglophone que ce guide
n’est pas le premier, mais le plus moderne,
et probablement — à lire les commentaires
— le meilleur.
Maintenant, comment résumer clairement l’intrigue
du roman ?
Ce n’est pas simple, parce que justement,
il ne s’agit pas d’un roman. On l’a
rangé dans cette catégorie par commodité.
Mais c’est un OVNI dans la littérature.
Joyce lui-même a dit que c’est, je cite,
« un genre d’encyclopédie ». Cette encyclopédie
compile des aventures urbaines, des dialogues
intérieurs profonds, des références historiques
et mythologiques, et même des exercices de
style littéraire.
Étant donné cette originalité, je vais
vous parler des quelques aspects qui me paraissent
essentiels pour comprendre le contenu du livre.
Quel est le sens du titre, tout d’abord
? Ulysse est un héros de la mythologie grecque,
connu pour son intelligence (c’est lui qui
a eu l’idée du cheval de Troie). Une fois
la guerre de Troie terminée, il fait un long
et périlleux voyage pour rentrer chez lui
— et c’est ce que raconte L’Odyssée
d’Homère. James Joyce a baptisé son roman
Ulysse parce qu’il raconte la série d’aventures
du protagoniste de manière similaire aux
périples d'Ulysse dans l'épopée d’Homère
(à la fin, par exemple, le héros de Joyce
rentre chez lui comme le héros d’Homère
rentre à Ithaque). Joyce fait référence
aux aventures du héros grec, et parfois il
les parodie.
Autre aspect essentiel pour comprendre le
contenu du livre, toute l’histoire se déroule
en une seule journée de 1904, le fameux 16
juin qui est la date du Bloomsday dont j’ai
parlé au début (tout s’éclaire). Joyce
raconte la journée ordinaire à Dublin de
deux personnages. Leopold Bloom, qui représente
Ulysse, et Stephen Dedalus, équivalent de
Télémaque (mais Stephen n’est pas le fils
de Leopold comme Télémaque est le fils d’Ulysse).
Stephen est un jeune artiste et penseur qui
incarne le côté intellectuel et spirituel
de l’humanité. Leopold incarne, lui, le
côté sensoriel et matériel de l’humanité,
car il est un homme d’âge moyen plus terre
à terre (il pense à des choses comme la
nourriture, le sexe, et son travail). Molly
Bloom, la femme de Leopold, est le troisième
personnage (elle représente une version moderne
de Pénélope, la femme fidèle d'Ulysse).
L’histoire commence à 8 heures du matin,
et elle termine à 3 heures du matin le jour
suivant.
Dans le détail, l’histoire est subdivisée
en 18 épisodes. Le jeune Stephen est le personnage
central des 3 premiers épisodes ; les 12
épisodes suivants se concentrent sur Leopold
; les 3 derniers épisodes racontent le « retour
à la maison » — comme Ulysse à Ithaque
— de Leopold accompagné de Stephen. Les
scènes les plus emblématiques sont, au début
du 4ème épisode, la préparation du petit-déjeuner
par Léopold, qui apparaît comme un homme
ancré dans le quotidien (ce qui contraste
fortement avec les abstractions du reste du
roman) ; et autre scène emblématique, au
14ème épisode, la rencontre entre Leopold
et Stephen à la maternité, moment clé à
partir duquel leurs parcours fusionnent.
Comment expliquer l’énorme influence de
ce livre ?
Ulysse représente tout d’abord une révolution
narrative. Autrement dit, James Joyce raconte
une histoire comme personne avant lui. La
technique emblématique de cette révolution
narrative est le stream of consciousness (« courant
de conscience » en français). Il s’agit
d’une technique d’écriture qui consiste
à épouser et à refléter au plus près
les émois, les pensées, et les états d'âme
d'un personnage. Le premier auteur à l’employer
est le Français Édouard Dujardin dans sa
nouvelle Les lauriers sont coupés. Mais c’est
Joyce qui popularise la technique trente ans
plus tard, notamment avec le fameux monologue
intérieur de Molly Bloom à la fin d’Ulysse.
Une autre raison de l’influence de ce livre,
c’est qu’il repousse les limites du roman.
En fait, ce n’est plus un roman au sens
strict, c’est-à-dire une œuvre de fiction
en prose qui raconte la destinée d’un ou
de plusieurs personnages. Ulysse est bien
plus que ça. Comme il y a beaucoup de références
culturelles, certains spécialistes de la
littérature disent que ce livre est une sorte
de « texte total » qui dialogue avec l'ensemble
de la tradition occidentale. À cet égard,
ce roman illustre la théorie de l’« intertextualité
» (qui émergera dans les années 1960).
Cette théorie dit que tout texte est lié
à d'autres textes, soit par des références
explicites, soit par des thèmes et des idées
similaires.
Enfin, dernière dimension essentielle de
l’influence de ce livre, il est devenu un
symbole de l’Irlande, un trait de l’identité
culturelle irlandaise. En effet, l’intrigue
est enracinée dans le paysage et la culture
de Dublin. Cela a contribué à mettre cette
ville et, par extension, l'Irlande elle-même,
sur la carte littéraire mondiale. C’est
assez drôle, parce que le contenu est culturellement
cosmopolite, et James Joyce lui-même était
un cosmopolite qui a vécu la majeure partie
de sa vie ailleurs en Europe (il a d’ailleurs
terminé Ulysse à Paris).
11ème référence : Siddhartha (1922), Hermann
Hesse
Timothy Leary, le psychologue de Harvard qui
est passé à la postérité comme le grand
promoteur de l’usage spirituel des drogues
dans le mouvement hippie — Timothy Leary
a dit : « Avant votre session de LSD, lisez
Siddhartha ». Il rapproche la lecture de
ce roman de l’effet des psychédéliques
parce que lire Siddhartha est une expérience
transformatrice qui change la conscience et
la vision du monde du lecteur.
Ce roman est incontournable dans la culture
occidentale parce que c’est LE roman d’apprentissage
— un roman d’apprentissage est une histoire
qui suit le développement moral, psychologique
ou social vers la maturité d'un personnage
principal, généralement de la jeunesse à
l'âge adulte, à travers une série d'expériences
et d'épreuves — Siddhartha est LE roman
d’apprentissage de la révolution culturelle
des années 1960. Il se vend déjà bien lors
de sa première publication en 1922, mais
les ventes explosent dans les années 1950,
parce qu’il devient le roman initiatique
culte de la contre-culture qui émerge. Il
passe pour être un des livres les plus traduits
de tous les temps, et plus généralement
un des plus grands succès de l’histoire
de l’édition. Le mouvement hippie n’est
plus une réalité contemporaine en Occident,
mais Siddhartha continue de se vendre comme
des petits pains. Aux États-Unis, la coutume
veut qu’on l’offre à la cérémonie de
remise de diplômes du lycée et de l’université,
parce que c’est un livre qui aide à trouver
sa voie. Il est également beaucoup lu par
les personnes qui connaissent une crise existentielle.
Une des raisons de l’extraordinaire succès
de ce roman, c’est qu’il est facile à
lire. Tout d’abord, il est court : une centaine
de pages (sans compter les introductions et
les préfaces). Ensuite, la prose de Herman
Hesse est d’une simplicité qui rappelle
la simplicité de la Bible, et plus généralement
des textes religieux (qui ne peuvent pas conquérir
les masses s’ils ne sont pas clairs). Les
phrases sont longues, mais la syntaxe et le
vocabulaire ne posent aucun problème. Le
style a une pureté qui fait penser à la
parole d’un guide spirituel. Ce style est
si spécial que les lecteurs disent qu’ils
ont l’impression que le livre leur parle.
Maintenant, je vous résume rapidement l’histoire.
Le titre du roman est le nom du héros, « Siddhartha
», qui signifie « celui qui a atteint son
but ». C’est le même nom que le Bouddha
historique, Siddhartha Gautama, mais le personnage
de Herman Hesse est fictif — il n’incarne
pas le Bouddha historique.
Né dans une famille aisée de brahmanes (la
classe sociale la plus élevée en Inde),
Siddhartha ressent le besoin de quitter son
confort familial pour chercher un sens plus
profond à la vie. Il quitte son village avec
son ami Govinda pour suivre des shramanas,
des ascètes qui prônent le renoncement aux
biens matériels et émotionnels. Ainsi, pendant
trois ans, Siddhartha et son ami pratiquent
l'ascétisme. Mais ils comprennent que cette
voie ne leur apporte pas l'illumination qu’ils
espéraient.
Ils entendent parler de Gotama, un homme qui
aurait atteint l'illumination. Ils quittent
donc les shramanas pour rejoindre ce nouveau
guide. Conquis par la sagesse de Gotama, Govinda
décide de rester avec lui. Siddhartha, lui,
pense que la véritable sagesse ne peut pas
être enseignée et choisit de continuer sa
quête seul.
La suite de son aventure ressemble davantage
à une vie ordinaire. Il tombe amoureux d'une
belle courtisane et travaille pour un riche
marchand. Pendant plusieurs années, il s'enrichit
et s'adonne aux plaisirs de la vie. Seulement,
il se rend compte qu'il s'éloigne de sa quête
spirituelle. Sentant le besoin d’y retourner,
il abandonne tout et part, alors même que
la courtisane est enceinte de lui.
Il trouve refuge auprès d'un passeur du nom
de Vasudeva (ce personnage permet aux gens
de passer d’une rive à l’autre du fleuve,
mais symboliquement, il permet à Siddhartha
de passer à l’étape suivante de sa quête
spirituelle). Ils passent du temps au bord
d'un fleuve, où Siddhartha apprend à écouter
la nature. La courtisane et leur enfant arrivent
au bord du fleuve. Tuée par la morsure d’un
serpent, la mère laisse donc Siddhartha élever
leur fils avec le passeur Vasudeva au bord
du fleuve. Inspiré par le parcours de son
père, le fils s’enfuit pour, lui aussi,
suivre son propre chemin. Le père veut d’abord
retrouver son fils, puis il finit par accepter
sa décision avec sérénité.
Le passeur Vasudeva part, laissant Siddhartha
seul au bord du fleuve. Il finit par y trouver
la paix intérieure. Un jour, Govinda, son
ami d’enfance avec lequel il a commencé
son voyage — Govinda le retrouve. Siddhartha
lui explique que la sagesse ne peut être
enseignée, qu’elle doit être découverte
par soi-même. En l'embrassant sur le front,
Govinda comprend que Siddhartha a atteint
l'éveil qu'il cherchait tant.
Comment expliquer l’énorme influence de
ce livre ?
Sur le plan de la littérature, il renouvelle
la tradition (européenne) du roman d’apprentissage.
Bien que Herman Hesse choisisse pour son histoire
un contexte loin, dans l’espace et dans
le temps, de l’Europe du XXe siècle, Siddhartha
est devenu un roman d’apprentissage universel,
toujours apprécié par les étudiants américains
du XXIe siècle.
Du point de vue de la culture, plus largement,
ce roman a été un des premiers à introduire
massivement les concepts de la spiritualité
orientale au public occidental. Les gens ont
cru à tort que Herman Hesse était lui-même
bouddhiste. Il était resté fidèle au protestantisme
de ses parents, et il défendait une spiritualité
universelle, sans doctrine précise.
La portée philosophique de ce roman ne se
résume donc pas à la spiritualité orientale.
En Occident, Siddharta est emblématique de
la nouvelle spiritualité critique de la société
de consommation qui émerge au cours des Trente
Glorieuses — et qui inspire notamment le
mouvement hippie. Une des caractéristiques
essentielles de cette nouvelle spiritualité
est qu’elle individualise la quête spirituelle,
c’est-à-dire que chacun doit suivre sa
propre voie et trouver ses propres réponses
(alors que les grandes religions occidentales
fournissent des réponses génériques). Cette
spiritualité est en partie inspirée par
la psychanalyse de Jung (qui est lui aussi
une source du renouveau spirituel des années
1960). Non seulement Herman Hesse s’était
beaucoup intéressé à la psychanalyse, mais
il avait fait 70 séances avec un disciple
de Jung quelques années avant d’écrire
Siddharta.
12ème référence : Le Procès (1925), Franz
Kafka
Fin 2020, les autorités françaises confinent
le pays pour une deuxième fois. Elles décident
quelles activités suspendre. Les examens
du permis de conduire sont maintenus. Les
inspecteurs sont au boulot, prêts à évaluer
les candidats. Oui mais… dans le même temps,
les autorités ont fermé les auto-écoles.
Résultat ? Les candidats ne peuvent pas se
préparer à l’examen qui est maintenu.
C’est ce qu’on appelle une situation « kafkaïenne
». L’adjectif est revenu à la mode parce
que les Français s’en sont servis pour
qualifier les dérives de l’administration
dans la gestion de la pandémie. Les auto-attestations
ou encore certaines règles en matière de
distanciation sociale ont nourri le sentiment
d’une absurdité bureaucratique.
L’adjectif « kafkaïen », que beaucoup
de gens emploient sans jamais avoir ouvert
un livre de Kafka — cet adjectif vient principalement
de ce roman, Le Procès. Il est donc incontournable
dans la culture occidentale parce qu’il
symbolise l’absurdité de la bureaucratie.
C’est certes un thème précis, mais l’administration
s’est tellement développée en Occident
depuis les Trente Glorieuses — avec l’émergence
de ce qu’on appelle « l’État-providence
» — l’administration s’est tellement
développée que l’individu occidental ordinaire
doit composer avec la bureaucratie — et
parfois ses dysfonctionnements — dans son
existence quotidienne. Donc ce roman est une
histoire bien utile pour comprendre le monde.
Il est considéré de nos jours comme le deuxième
plus important roman de langue allemande après
Les Souffrances du jeune Werther de Goethe.
Qu’en dire sur la forme ?
C’est un livre relativement court : plus
ou moins 200 pages selon les éditions. De
prime abord, le style de Kafka est très clair.
Dans les phrases, les propositions sont courtes,
la syntaxe est élémentaire, et le vocabulaire
est simple. Mais cette clarté est de surface.
En fait, la lecture n’est pas si facile,
car la prose de Kafka cultive l’ambiguïté.
Comme aiment à le faire les romanciers emblématiques
du nouveau modèle d’écriture qui s’impose
au XXe siècle, Kafka n’explique pas tout
clairement — il laisse place à l’interprétation.
Enfin, les paragraphes sont parfois bien longs,
ce qui a pour effet de renforcer le sentiment
d’oppression qu’inspire l’histoire.
Je vous la résume rapidement.
Le héros, Josef K., est cadre dans une banque.
Un matin, il est arrêté. On ne lui dit pas
pourquoi — ce détail, qui est contraire
au droit à un procès équitable, sera essentiel
dans la postérité du livre. Bien qu’il
soit arrêté, Joseph K. n'est pas mis en
prison : il peut continuer sa vie normalement
en attendant son procès. Sa logeuse pense
que son arrestation est liée à une liaison
avec sa voisine. Josef K. va rendre visite
à cette voisine et l'embrasse. Plus tard,
il découvre qu'une autre locataire emménage
avec sa voisine, et il pense qu’elle l’accueille
afin de prendre ses distances avec lui.
Un dimanche, Josef K. doit se présenter devant
le tribunal. Il trouve finalement la salle
dans un grenier. Il est en retard. Il essaie
de se défendre, mais agace encore plus les
juges. Josef K. tente de parler au juge pour
comprendre son affaire. Il découvre ensuite
les agents qui l'ont arrêté en train d'être
fouettés. Il essaie de les aider, en vain.
Son oncle lui présente un avocat, Herr Huld.
Mais comme Josef K. a des doutes, il consulte
le peintre officiel du tribunal. Selon ce
dernier, l'acquittement est peu probable.
Josef K. se rend chez l’avocat afin de le
renvoyer. Il y rencontre un autre client,
un négociant dénommé M. Block. Ce M. Block
lui donne des conseils alors même qu’il
a, lui, tout perdu à cause de son procès
qui dure depuis plus de cinq ans, et que cette
situation le place dans une dépendance extrême
par rapport à l’avocat.
Ensuite, Josef K. accompagne un important
client devant la cathédrale de la ville.
Un prêtre l’interpelle et lui conte ce
qu’on appelle la « parabole de la loi ». Dans
cette parabole, un homme est le seul à attendre
des années devant une porte menant à « la
loi », et il apprend avant de mourir qu’il
ne pourra finalement pas y entrer. Cette parabole
signifie que la justice, et plus généralement
l’administration, sont des systèmes faits
par et pour des initiés, et qu’ils sont
impénétrables pour les hommes ordinaires.
Le roman finit avec l’exécution de Josef
K. Deux hommes se rendent chez lui la veille
de son 31ème anniversaire. Ils l’exécutent
sommairement avec un couteau de boucher, « comme
un chien », commente Josef K. avant d’expirer.
Le Procès est un chef-d’œuvre qui a laissé
une empreinte indélébile sur la littérature
et la culture occidentale. Et pourtant, il
a été publié de manière posthume par un
ami de Kafka contre la volonté expresse de
Kafka, qui voulait qu’on brûle ses écrits.
Première dimension essentielle de l’influence
de ce roman, il contribue au renouvellement
du genre. Kafka y brise les conventions narratives,
en optant pour une histoire sans résolution
claire et en laissant de nombreuses questions
sans réponse. Cela inspirera les auteurs
ultérieurs à expérimenter avec le roman.
Ensuite, la deuxième dimension essentielle
de l’influence du Procès tient à la lecture
politique qu’on peut en faire. Il connaît
une véritable vogue au début des Trente
Glorieuses parce que le grand public y voit
une dénonciation des bureaucraties totalitaires,
policières en particulier, de l’Allemagne
nazie et de l’URSS. À partir de la fin
des Trente Glorieuses, il symbolise plus généralement
l’expansion de la bureaucratie.
Enfin, la troisième dimension essentielle
de l’influence de ce roman tient à la lecture
philosophique qu’on peut en faire. Si Le
Procès devient très populaire dans l’après-guerre,
c’est parce que le public cultivé voit
en Josef K. un héros existentialiste. Ainsi,
l’idée du procès qu’on ne peut pas gagner
ne représenterait pas simplement l’absurdité
du système judiciaire, de l’administration
moderne, ou même de toute structure sociale,
mais plus fondamentalement l’absurdité
de la condition humaine. D’après cette
lecture, le héros de Kafka serait donc un
précurseur des héros de Sartre et de Camus.
13ème référence : Gatsby le Magnifique
(1925), Francis Scott Fitzgerald
Vous avez peut-être vu passer ce mème sur
internet ou sur les réseaux sociaux : Leonardo
Di Caprio en costume, qui lève une coupe
de champagne avec un sourire narquois (je
crois même que mon monteur l’a déjà utilisé
pour une de mes vidéos). Eh bien cette image
virale est tirée de l’adaptation au cinéma
de ce roman. Vous avez peut-être également
entendu parler, plus récemment, de l’émission
de podcast qui raconte le destin d’Oussama
Amar, la figure emblématique du monde des
start-up en France (il y a même eu une campagne
de pub dans le métro parisien). Cette émission
a été baptisée « Oussama le magnifique
» en référence — à ma connaissance — à
ce roman.
Ce livre paru il y a presque 100 ans est donc
encore une référence incontournable dans
la culture occidentale en 2023. C’est un
des plus grands chefs-d'œuvre de la littérature
américaine, et même de la littérature de
langue anglaise. Il est d’autant plus important
aux États-Unis qu’il est un grand classique
des cours de littérature (tous les Américains
en ont donc au moins entendu parler au collège
ou au lycée). Sur le plan des idées, Gatsby
le Magnifique est une des critiques romanesques,
sinon la critique romanesque la plus célèbre
de ce qu’on appelle le « rêve américain
», c’est-à-dire l’idée que n’importe
qui peut réussir socialement (surtout économiquement)
aux États-Unis grâce à son travail acharné
et à sa détermination. En critiquant le
rêve américain, ce roman critique plus fondamentalement
l’idée que la réussite sociale apporte
le bonheur.
Pour l’anecdote, ce livre est né en France…
grâce au dollar fort ! Au début des années
1920, un dollar permet d’obtenir beaucoup
de francs, ce qui veut dire qu’en ayant
des revenus en dollars et des dépenses en
francs, on décuple son niveau de vie. Fitzgerald
se rend sur la côte d’azur pour profiter
de cette situation. Il écrit Gatsby le Magnifique
dans une petite ville à 60km à l’ouest
de Nice, Saint-Raphaël, où, enfant, j’ai
passé une partie de mes vacances chez mes
grands-parents. Seconde partie de l’anecdote
: Fitzgerald fera lire le manuscrit de ce
roman à Hemingway à Paris, à la terrasse
de La Closerie des Lilas, une brasserie huppée
qui était un repère d’écrivains et d’intellectuels
dans le quartier Montparnasse (c’est aujourd’hui
un restaurant gastronomique).
Que dire de la forme de ce roman ?
C’est un livre d’un peu plus de 200 pages
(au format poche), et en enlevant les préfaces,
il y en a plutôt pour 170 pages. Bien que
les phrases soient souvent longues, la prose
de Fitzgerald est claire. L’écriture est
travaillée et élégante, sans que ces qualités
ne rendent la lecture plus difficile. Le style
est globalement efficace. Les descriptions
sont peu nombreuses et subtiles. Les péripéties
s'enchaînent avec fluidité.
Je passe au résumé de l’histoire.
Le narrateur n’est pas Gatsby, mais Nick.
Nick est un jeune Américain privilégié
passé par la prestigieuse université Yale.
Il arrive à New York au printemps 1922 pour
travailler dans la finance. Il loue une petite
maison à Long Island, la grande île située
à l'est de la ville et qui est un peu le
terrain de jeu des riches. Nick est voisin
d'un manoir luxueux appartenant à Jay Gatsby,
un mystérieux millionnaire qui organise des
fêtes somptueuses.
Un soir, Nick dîne chez sa cousine Daisy
et son mari Tom, qui vivent de l'autre côté
de la baie. Le personnage de Tom représente
la classe sociale des héritiers, tandis que
le personnage de Gatsby représente les nouveaux
riches. Nick aperçoit Gatsby ce soir-là,
mais leur première rencontre survient peu
après. Invité à une fête chez Gatsby,
Nick se rend compte que peu d’invités connaissent
leur hôte, un beau dandy qui parle avec un
accent anglais. Nick remarque que sa cousine
Daisy obsède Gatsby.
Fin juillet, Gatsby et le narrateur Nick se
revoient lors d’un déjeuner. Gatsby raconte
à Nick ses exploits de guerre et ses études
à Oxford. Il prétend venir d’une riche
famille de San Francisco. Jordan, une amie
de Daisy (la cousine de Nick), révèle à
Nick que Gatsby et Daisy étaient en couple
avant que Gatsby ne parte à la guerre. Et
maintenant qu’il est riche, Gatsby espère
reconquérir Daisy. Il demande donc à Nick
d’organiser une rencontre. À partir de
cette rencontre, Daisy et Gatsby entament
une relation.
En septembre, Tom, le mari de Daisy, découvre
qu’elle le trompe. Lors d’une mise au
point entre les trois personnages, Tom révèle
à sa femme que Gatsby s’est enrichi en
trafiquant de l’alcool (c’était l’époque
de la prohibition aux États-Unis), ce qui
détruit la réputation que Gatsby a soigneusement
construite. Sommée par Gatsby de dire qu’en
réalité elle n’a jamais aimé son mari,
Daisy refuse, et choisit même de rester avec
son mari. Confiant dans le choix de sa femme,
Tom autorise Gatsby à la ramener en voiture.
Sur le chemin, Gatsby laisse Daisy conduire
afin qu’elle se calme. Mais elle tue une
femme, qui n’est autre que la maîtresse
de son mari Tom. Gatsby prend le blâme pour
protéger Daisy. Le mari de la femme tuée
pense que le conducteur du véhicule est l’homme
avec lequel sa femme le trompait. Donc il
tue Gatsby avant de se suicider.
Il n’y a presque personne aux funérailles
de Gatsby. Le narrateur se met à haïr New
York. Il pense que Gatsby, sa cousine, son
mari, et lui — tous originaires de la partie
centrale des États-Unis (le Midwest) — ne
sont pas faits pour l’Est du pays. Il quitte
New York.
Comment résumer l’influence de ce roman
dans la littérature et la culture occidentales
?
En premier lieu, comme je l’ai dit au début,
Gatsby le Magnifique incarne la critique du
rêve américain. Gatsby s’est enrichi rapidement,
mais de manière illégale. Autre dimension
de la critique, Gatsby n’est pas épanoui
socialement. Les gens qui se rendent à ses
fêtes ne sont pas de véritables amis — ils
savent à peine qui il est. Enfin, tout son
argent ne peut pas acheter ce qui a le plus
de valeur à ses yeux, l’amour de Daisy.
L’influence de Gatsby le Magnifique tient
également à son intérêt historique. Fitzgerald
dépeint à travers la jet-set new-yorkaise
l’hédonisme des années 1920, l’époque
qu’on appelle les « années folles ». Après
la Première Guerre mondiale, l’Occident
connaît une explosion d'énergie créative,
d'optimisme ; et la société change vite.
On appelle également cette période les « années
jazz » parce que la diffusion du jazz (notamment
grâce à la radio) — la diffusion du jazz
depuis les États-Unis incarne l’énergie
créative de l’époque.
Enfin, l’influence de Gatsby le Magnifique
tient également à son intérêt sociologique.
Aux États-Unis, les années 1920 sont celles
de l’émergence de la société de consommation
et d’un nouveau rapport à la richesse,
symbolisé dans le roman par l’opposition
entre Tom, l’héritier passé par Yale,
et Gatsby, le nouveau riche qui s’est sali
les mains pour réaliser le rêve américain.
Les fêtes et les énormes dépenses de Gatsby
illustrent le concept de la consommation ostentatoire
du sociologue américain Veblen : dans le
capitalisme industriel, la valeur sociale
est désormais réduite à l’argent, c’est
pourquoi l’élite sociale étale sa richesse
— comme Gatsby — pour donner la preuve
de son statut. Ainsi, ce roman révèle déjà
la logique de la consommation expliquée par
Baudrillard 45 ans plus tard : dans la société
de consommation, on consomme pour exprimer
son statut.
14ème référence : Les raisins de la colère
(1939), John Steinbeck
Ce roman est le premier livre que j’ai lu
en anglais sans dictionnaire. J’aurais bien
utilisé un dictionnaire, mais en fait je
n’en avais pas. C’était l’été de
mes 19 ans, que je passais à traverser les
États-Unis en autostop avec mon meilleur
ami. J’ai mis la main sur une vieille édition
de poche délabrée dans une énorme librairie
au Texas. Pour moins d’un dollar, j’ai
tué beaucoup de temps avec une histoire qui
m’a impressionné et qui m’a fait relativiser
les conditions difficiles dans lesquelles
mon ami et moi nous sommes parfois retrouvés.
En effet, Les raisins de la colère est le
roman emblématique de la misère sociale
de la Grande Dépression, la crise économique
des années 1930 qui commence par le krach
de 1929, et qui restera la plus grave crise
économique du XXe siècle. Les raisins de
la colère est plus généralement un des
meilleurs romans de la littérature occidentale
sur le thème de la misère. C’est une des
raisons pour lesquelles John Steinbeck remportera
le prix Nobel de littérature en 1962.
Concernant la forme, c’est un gros livre
de plus de 600 pages. Après, le style de
Steinbeck est simple : les phrases sont souvent
courtes ; le vocabulaire est juste, sans être
compliqué. Les descriptions sont parfois
un peu longues pour un lecteur de 2023. Les
dialogues en argot font très réaliste et
nous plongent dans l’identité sociale spécifique
des personnages (qui sont de pauvres fermiers
du centre des États-Unis) — mais je me
souviens qu’il m’avait fallu du temps
pour m’adapter aux dialogues en argot en
lisant en anglais.
Maintenant, je vous résume l’intrigue.
Tom Joad revient chez lui après avoir purgé
une peine de prison. En route, il rencontre
Jim Casy, un ancien pasteur ; puis il découvre
que sa famille a dû abandonner leur ferme
en Oklahoma. Poussés par la sécheresse et
la mécanisation des terres par les grands
propriétaires — qui sont souvent des banques
— la famille Joad et l’ancien pasteur
Casy préparent un voyage vers la Californie,
perçue comme un Eldorado. Ces migrants originaires
de l'Oklahoma seront appelés « Okies » (O
K I E S).
La famille Joad entame un périlleux voyage
sur la route 66, la mythique route américaine
des grandes migrations, qui traverse le pays
de Chicago, au nord-est, jusqu’à la Californie,
au sud-ouest. Les Joad côtoient d'autres
familles qui fuient la misère comme eux.
L'entraide est cruciale tout au long de la
route. Malgré les obstacles et les pertes
en chemin, les Joad continuent à espérer
une vie meilleure en Californie.
Mais une fois arrivés, les rêves se transforment
rapidement en cauchemar. Considérés comme
des agitateurs et des marginaux, les Joad
sont accueillis avec méfiance, voire avec
hostilité par les habitants et les riches
propriétaires de terres. Les Joad sont même
considérés comme des sous-hommes. Il faut
dire que le flot perpétuel des émigrants
fait régner la panique dans l’Ouest. La
concurrence est féroce pour des emplois mal
rémunérés, et les conditions de travail
sont souvent précaires.
Chaque fois que les Joad trouvent du travail,
comme la cueillette de pêches ou la coupure
du coton, l'espoir renaît brièvement — puis
ils sont écrasés par l'exploitation et la
pauvreté. Les salaires versés ne sont pas
les salaires promis, et ils peuvent baisser
du jour au lendemain. Les tentatives de grève
sont brutalement réprimées par la police.
La famille Joad supporte sa situation grâce
à l’amour qui unit ses membres. Ils sont
accablés par la misère, mais ils sont aussi
en colère (d’où le titre du roman). Trouvé
par la femme de Steinbeck, ce titre reprend
une image de l’Apocalypse (le dernier livre
de l’Ancien Testament, dans La Bible). La
récolte des raisins symbolise l’idée que
les responsables de l’injustice subie par
la famille Joad — les exploiteurs vont récolter
les fruits du mal qu’ils font. La colère
et la justice divine vont s’abattre sur
eux.
Comment résumer l’influence de ce roman
dans la littérature et la culture occidentales
?
La première dimension est qu’il a développé
la conscience sociale américaine, et plus
généralement occidentale. Steinbeck dépeint
puissamment la misère des Okies : les familles
qui s’entassent dans les camps de migrants
; les journées de travail exténuantes dans
les champs pour des salaires dérisoires ; la
stigmatisation sociale par les habitants locaux
et par les autorités ; les conséquences
de la misère sur la santé (la grand-mère
de la famille Joad meurt au cours du voyage,
et une des filles donne naissance à un bébé
mort-né). Les raisins de la colère est un
peu l’épopée américaine de la misère.
Du coup, Tom Joad et la famille Joad symbolisent
les pauvres américains dans la culture populaire.
L’icône du rock américain Bruce Springsteen
intitulera par exemple un de ses albums The
Ghost of Tom Joad (« Le fantôme de Tom Joad
», en français).
Une influence plus précise de ce roman dans
la culture occidentale est qu’il est une
des plus célèbres allégories de l’immigration.
La famille Joad incarne un déplacement historiquement
massif de population à travers les États-Unis
causé par la Grande Dépression. À travers
leur destin, le lecteur comprend l'expérience
de quitter sa terre natale sous la contrainte
de la misère, pour rejoindre un eldorado
fantasmé où, en plus de retrouver la misère,
on découvrira le mépris et même la déshumanisation.
Enfin, une autre dimension de l’influence
de ce roman dans la culture occidentale est
qu’il met en scène les mécanismes de l’exploitation
capitaliste. J’avais été frappé par le
processus de recrutement des riches propriétaires
agricoles de Californie : ils distribuent
bien plus de prospectus qu’ils n’ont d’emplois
à offrir, comme ça, ils embauchent les gens
qui acceptent de travailler aux salaires les
plus faibles. C’est une illustration concrète
de ce que Marx appelle « l’armée de réserve
» : la disponibilité des prolétaires sans
emploi fait pression sur les salaires des
prolétaires employés. Steinbeck montre également
comment les riches propriétaires agricoles
de Californie extorquent aux ouvriers la valeur
de leur travail, en réduisant sans cesse
les salaires, ou encore en rémunérant les
ouvriers en tickets échangeables à la boutique
du camp, où les prix sont gonflés. Et avant
même le voyage vers la Californie, Steinbeck
décrit le mécanisme implacable de l’usure,
grâce auquel les banques exproprient les
naïfs paysans de l’Oklahoma.
Vous aimez les gros manuels ?
Je sais bien, c’est pas une partie de plaisir.
Mais comment faire si vous voulez découvrir
les idées d’Aristote, par exemple ?
Eh bien allez sur le site 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Vous tapez « Aristote » dans la barre de
recherche, et vous avez les synthèses, des
synthèses très claires des meilleures idées
d’Aristote.
Rédigées avec amour et beaucoup de café,
par votre serviteur.
Et comme le nom l’indique, 1000 idées de
culture générale ce n’est pas que de la
philo.
Vous trouverez aussi les meilleures idées
en économie, en littérature, en histoire,
en science politique, en psychologie, etc.
Alors maintenant, que faire de ces gros manuels
?
Alors moi je les garde, parce qu’ils sont
bien pratiques pour remplir la bibliothèque
quand je tourne des vidéos.
Mais vous, vous pouvez vous en servir comme
support pour poser la casserole, ou bien pour
faire de la musculation, si vous n’aimez
pas les haltères classiques.
[Moi en train de soulever de gros manuels]
« C’est moins fatiguant que de les lire
! ».
Vous n’avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour découvrir le meilleur de la pensée.
Allez simplement sur le site 1000 idées de
culture générale.
15ème référence : Le Désert des Tartares
(1940), Dino Buzzati
À l’élection présidentielle de mai 1974,
seules 200 000 voix séparent Valéry Giscard
d’Estaing, le vainqueur, de François Mitterrand.
Moins d’un an plus tard, le journaliste
Bernard Pivot invite le perdant à Apostrophes,
l’émission littéraire culte de France
2. Et après le passage de Mitterrand dans
l’émission, beaucoup de gens pensent la
même chose : si cette émission avait eu
lieu avant l’élection présidentielle de
1974, imaginent-ils, la maigre avance de Valéry
Giscard d’Estaing aurait fondu. Les gens
qui ont vu l’émission pensent cela parce
que François Mitterrand y a été brillant.
Bernard Pivot estime qu’aucun autre invité
prestigieux, dans l’histoire de l’émission,
n’a réussi à commenter avec autant de
brio les livres dont il a choisi de parler.
Et c’est pendant les dix dernières minutes
de l’émission, en parlant de ce roman,
Le Désert des Tartares de Dino Buzzati, que
Mitterrand a été le plus éblouissant. D’après
Bernard Pivot, c’était « le silence absolu
sur le plateau ».
Le Désert des Tartares de Dino Buzzati est
incontournable dans la littérature occidentale
pour deux raisons. Tout d’abord, c’est
le roman de référence sur le thème du destin
manqué. C’est une allégorie qui montre
comment les hommes espèrent souvent que des
événements extérieurs viennent donner un
sens à leur vie. La seconde raison de l’importance
du Désert des Tartares est qu’il est un
des plus grands, sinon LE plus grand roman
italien. Il vaut à Buzzati d’être comparé
aux plus célèbres romanciers de la littérature
occidentale. Étant donné l’ambiance qui
se dégage de ce roman, Buzzati est appelé
« le Kafka italien ».
Concernant la forme, c’est un livre d’un
peu moins de 300 pages. Comme Buzzati était
journaliste, son style est à la fois simple
— même simpliste, critiquent certains — le
style de Buzzati est simple, réaliste, mais
en même temps poétique. Il varie la longueur
des phrases et des paragraphes ; le vocabulaire
ne pose aucun problème.
Maintenant, je vous résume l’histoire.
Giovanni Drogo est un jeune lieutenant affecté
au fort Bastiani, un poste frontière isolé.
Au-delà des murailles de ce fort s'étend
un désert qui donne son titre au roman, le
désert des Tartares. Mais ce nom ne désigne
pas précisément le peuple d’Asie centrale
— les « Tartares » symbolisent un ennemi
indéfini et mystérieux. Ce nom ajoute une
couche d'exotisme et d’énigme, et renforce
ainsi l’atmosphère d'incertitude qui imprègne
toute l’histoire.
Fasciné par le fort Bastiani et le paysage,
Drogo décide d'y rester malgré une première
envie de partir. Les mois s'étendent en années.
Chaque jour est rempli de l'attente d'une
attaque des ennemis du nord qui ne vient jamais.
Des choses se produisent au bout de deux ans.
Un cheval sans cavalier déclenche une fausse
alerte. Un soldat du fort est tué. Un officier
meurt de fatigue en mission. Au bout de quatre
ans, Drogo obtient une permission et retourne
brièvement en ville. Mais il se sent déconnecté
de sa vie passée. Il revient au fort, poussé
par des rumeurs d'activités ennemies au nord.
Mais l'attente continue. Après quinze ans
de présence, Drogo devient capitaine.
C’est après trente ans passés au fort
que les ennemis tant attendus se rapprochent
enfin. Mais Drogo est trop malade pour participer
à la bataille. Rapatrié vers la ville, il
croise des renforts montant au front. Il termine
ses jours dans une petite auberge, ayant attendu
toute sa vie un événement qui ne s’est
jamais produit.
Comment expliquer l’influence de ce roman
dans la littérature et la culture occidentales
?
En premier lieu, son thème principal, le
destin manqué, est universel. Les hommes
espèrent souvent que des événements extérieurs
viennent donner un sens à leur vie. Comme
Drogo qui attend l’attaque des ennemis du
nord, les gens attendent que leur travail,
leurs relations, la gloire ou une forme d’accomplissement
personnel — les gens ont tendance à projeter
leur épanouissement dans des circonstances
futures. Le Désert des Tartares est donc
une allégorie de la quête infructueuse,
car passive, de bonheur et de sens.
Une autre raison de l’influence de ce roman
est sa saveur existentialiste. Bien que Buzzati
n’ait pas cherché à écrire un roman existentialiste,
Le Désert des Tartares est souvent associé
au courant de l’existentialisme. Et plutôt
à raison : l’atmosphère d’absurdité
qui émane du récit et le message philosophique
du roman sont comme la signature de l’existentialisme.
Buzzati était d’ailleurs proche de Camus
qui, comme lui, est catégorisé comme un
auteur existentialiste alors qu’il n’a
pas lui-même revendiqué ou accepté l’étiquette.
L’atmosphère et les thèmes du Désert
des Tartares font également passer Buzzati
pour un héritier de Kafka. Comme lui, il
décrit l’impuissance humaine dans un monde
incompréhensible. Enfin, en raison du thème
spécial de l’attente absurde, Le Désert
des Tartares est parfois présenté, sur le
plan du message philosophique, comme l’équivalent
romanesque de la pièce de théâtre En attendant
Godot.
Enfin, l’influence de ce roman dans la littérature
et la culture occidentales tient également
— mais dans une moindre mesure — à la
critique de la guerre. Buzzati dépeint la
monotonie et l’absurdité qui imprègnent
la vie militaire dans l’attente du combat.
Cela me fait penser à ce que mon père me
disait à propos de son service militaire
: « j’ai appris à attendre ». Le Désert
des Tartares dissipe donc la vision romantique
de l’héroïsme militaire.
16ème référence : 1984 (1949), George Orwell
Je passe beaucoup de temps sur Amazon. Je
commande beaucoup de livres, mais je flâne
aussi sur le site et sur l’application comme
je flânais dans les librairies lorsque j’habitais
à Paris. Je regarde attentivement les couvertures
; je lis les présentations des éditeurs
et les commentaires. Si je fais la queue au
supermarché, je sors mon téléphone pour
découvrir des livres sur l’application
Amazon. Lorsque j’écris un script pour
parler d’un livre particulier, je passe
toujours un bon moment à comparer les éditions
sur Amazon. Pour ce roman, je me rends sur
le site américain d’Amazon, et qu’est-ce
que je vois : près de 111 000 notes, avec
une moyenne de 4,6 sur 5 ! Et plus de 10 000
commentaires ! Il a plus de notes que La Bible
ou que Harry Potter ! J’ai décidé de commencer
par vous parler de ça parce que je n’ai
jamais vu une telle quantité de notes sur
Amazon pour un livre classique, ni même pour
un livre tout court (même si c’est vrai
que je m’intéresse peu aux nouveautés).
Et du coup, par curiosité, j’ai cherché
un classement des meilleures ventes de tous
les temps sur Amazon, et le résultat est
cohérent avec les 111 000 notes : 1984 d’Orwell
est le 16ème livre le plus vendu de tous
les temps sur Amazon !
Que ce roman classique de 1949 rivalise commercialement
avec Harry Potter et Cinquante nuances de
Grey est révélateur : il est bien plus qu’un
livre ; il est un symbole important dans l’imaginaire
collectif occidental. 1984 est une référence
littéraire incontournable parce qu’il est,
et de loin, la plus célèbre dystopie jamais
écrite (une « dystopie », ou contre-utopie,
est un récit de fiction qui dénonce les
travers d’une société imaginaire). Vous
connaissez peut-être également Le meilleur
des mondes d’Aldous Huxley, Fahrenheit 451
de Ray Bradbury, ou encore Les monades urbaines
de Robert Silverberg — mais ces romans n’ont
pas l’empreinte de 1984 sur la culture occidentale.
Pour faire simple, 1984 symbolise la propagande
et le totalitarisme. Apple s’est par exemple
servi du symbole qu’est ce roman pour sa
légendaire pub de 1984 diffusée pendant
le Super Bowl (la finale du championnat de
football américain). Cette pub montre une
femme qui détruit un écran géant, l’instrument
du totalitarisme dans le roman, avec un marteau.
L’idée de la pub est que le Macintosh d’Apple
nous libère de la conformité imposée par
les autres entreprises informatiques.
Sur le plan de la forme, 1984 compte entre
300 et 400 pages selon les éditions. Le style
d’Orwell est simple, direct, sans ornements.
Cette simplicité incarne d’abord sa vision
du langage. Dans son essai Politics and the
English Language (« La politique et la langue
anglaise » en français) — dans cet essai,
Orwell affirme, je cite, « penser clairement
est la première étape nécessaire vers la
régénération politique ». Or, à ses yeux,
il faut écrire clairement pour être capable
de penser clairement (c’est une idée profonde,
mais ce n’est pas du tout une idée neuve
— les auteurs français de l’âge classique
avaient déjà mis en évidence le lien entre
la qualité de l’écriture et la qualité
de la pensée). La simplicité du style de
1984 sert également à exprimer la monotonie
et l’oppression de la vie dans une société
totalitaire. Orwell sort parfois de cette
simplicité pour refléter l’état émotionnel
du héros, comme lorsque le héros écrit
dans son journal intime.
Je passe au résumé de l’histoire.
Le héros s’appelle Winston Smith. Il vit
en 1984 dans un pays (fictif) dénommé l’Océania,
où l’État est totalitaire. Comme dans
les régimes totalitaires historiques, c’est
le Parti (avec un grand P), et son leader,
Big Brother (aussi appelé « Le Grand Frère
» ou « Tonton » dans certaines traductions
françaises) — ce sont le parti unique et
son chef qui ont la main sur l’État. Winston
est employé au Ministère de la Vérité.
Son métier consiste à réécrire l'histoire
afin qu’elle colle à la propagande du Parti.
Trois slogans régissent cette société totalitaire
: « La guerre, c'est la paix » ; « La liberté,
c'est l'esclavage » (ce qui, pour le coup,
peut signifier quelque chose de juste en philosophie,
par rapport à la logique du désir humain)
; dernier slogan de la société totalitaire
du roman, « L'ignorance, c'est la force » (cette
idée-ci est bien moins justifiable). Les
autorités entretiennent la haine de la population
envers Emmanuel Goldstein, l’ennemi public
numéro un, auteur d’un livre subversif.
Les autorités surveillent la population à
travers les « télécrans », des écrans
installés dans presque tous les espaces publics
et privés, et qui servent à la fois de téléviseurs
et de caméras.
Winston a beau travailler pour le système
totalitaire, il n’est pas un mouton. Il
se méfie du Parti. Mais bien sûr, il ne
peut pas exprimer ses doutes. Écrire un journal
intime est déjà un acte de rébellion, donc
Winston écrit en cachette, avec la crainte
perpétuelle d'être découvert par la Police
de la Pensée.
Un jour, Winston rencontre Julia. Elle lui
déplaît au début, parce qu’il croit qu’elle
est une espionne du pouvoir. Mais surprise
: elle lui glisse un mot où elle a écrit
« Je vous aime ». Ils entament alors une
relation secrète et louent même une chambre
pour leurs rendez-vous. Ils partagent la même
haine du Parti. Alors que Winston envisage
une révolution, Julia veut simplement vivre
sa vie. Ils sont finalement découverts par
le propriétaire de la chambre, qui était
un agent infiltré. La Police de la Pensée
les arrête.
Winston est torturé au Ministère de l’Amour
par O'Brien. O'Brien n’est pas n’importe
qui : c’est un collègue, membre du Parti
intérieur, l’élite politique de l’État
totalitaire — mais O'Brien s’était présenté
à Winston comme un révolutionnaire. Il est
en réalité un membre loyal du parti chargé
de traquer les dissidents. O'Brien rééduque
Winston au point de le faire trahir Julia.
Mais à sa libération, Winston découvre
que Julia et lui se sont trahis mutuellement,
ce qui détruit leur amour. Apprenant par
la propagande que l’armée vient d’obtenir
une victoire surprise, Winston se met à aimer
Big Brother.
La progression de l’histoire fait naître
une conviction chez le lecteur : l’ennemi
public numéro un Goldstein pourrait bien
être une invention du Parti lui-même, créé
pour servir de bouc émissaire qui focalise
le mécontentement du peuple. De même, le
livre de Goldstein qui a révélé à Winston
les objectifs et les méthodes du Parti — le
livre subversif de Goldstein pourrait également
être une fabrication, destinée à attraper
ceux qui pensent de manière subversive. Le
roman laisse cette question ouverte.
Maintenant, comment résumer l’exceptionnelle
influence de 1984 sur la littérature et la
culture occidentales ? Je vais me limiter
aux trois dimensions de cette influence qui
me paraissent les plus essentielles.
Sur le plan de la littérature, tout d’abord,
1984 popularise le genre dystopique et sert
de modèle dans ce genre. Il pose des conventions
narratives que reprendront les auteurs ultérieurs
du genre, notamment la description d’un
pouvoir politique qui voit tout, qui pratique
la désinformation, et qui réprime la pensée
non conforme. Il lance également des thèmes
clés du genre dystopique moderne, comme la
manipulation du langage ou la déshumanisation
des individus dans un régime totalitaire.
Les deux autres dimensions essentielles de
l’influence de 1984 concernent son message
politique.
Il y a d’abord la question de la surveillance.
Big Brother est devenu le symbole de la surveillance
de masse par l’État, et plus profondément
de la disparition de la vie privée. À l’époque
d’Orwell, les autorités ne pouvaient surveiller
leur population qu’en faisant un usage exacerbé
de l’espionnage, comme en Allemagne de l’Est
lors de la guerre froide (où on estime qu’un
citoyen sur cent était informateur pour la
police politique) ; mais les technologies
disponibles en 2023 sont désormais supérieures
aux télécrans imaginés par Orwell (et qui
sait ce que l’avenir nous réserve).
La troisième dimension essentielle de l’influence
de 1984 concerne la propagande. Orwell évoque
les techniques de base, comme le culte de
la personnalité. Mais les techniques avancées
de conditionnement décrites dans le roman
montrent que la propagande vise ultimement
le contrôle de la pensée. Les deux techniques
emblématiques du roman, ce sont la manipulation
de la langue et la réécriture de l’histoire.
Concernant la langue, Orwell imagine que l’État
totalitaire impose une nouvelle langue, la
« novlangue », qui rende impossible l’expression
d’idées subversives. Cette « novlangue
» repose sur l’hypothèse selon laquelle
ce qu’on peut dire, la langue, détermine
ce qu’on peut penser, c’est-à-dire que
les représentations mentales dépendent des
catégories linguistiques. Le terme « novlangue
» est entré dans le vocabulaire courant
pour qualifier une expression ou un discours
qui dissimule ou trahit la réalité en mêlant
la langue de bois et le politiquement correct
(par exemple, un responsable politique peut
qualifier de « dialogue constructif » des
négociations qui n’ont en réalité abouti
à rien).
Concernant la seconde technique de propagande
emblématique du roman, la réécriture de
l’histoire, Orwell imagine que l’État
totalitaire profite de son contrôle des archives
pour retoucher, voire détruire le passé.
Ça, ce n’est pas de la fiction. J’ai
par exemple lu dans la biographie de Staline
que lorsqu’il se débarrassait d’un membre
de l’élite soviétique, il faisait modifier
les encyclopédies de l’URSS, au ciseau
et à la colle, afin de minimiser le rôle
de l’individu en question dans l’histoire
de l’URSS, voire de supprimer son existence
dans la mémoire collective. « Qui commande
le passé, écrit Orwell dans 1984, commande
l’avenir, qui commande le présent, commande
le passé ». Cette forme exacerbée de propagande
met en évidence deux idées intéressantes,
mais controversées, à propos de l’histoire.
Première idée, l’histoire est écrite
par les gagnants, par les hommes qui détiennent
le pouvoir. Seconde idée intéressante : le
passé n’existe pas dans l’absolu, indépendamment
d’un biais d’interprétation. Ce serait
le même phénomène qu’à l’échelle
individuelle : les souvenirs ne sont pas objectifs,
parce que la mémoire transforme la réalité
passée.
Voilà pour les deux dimensions du message
politique de 1984.
Ce sont ces deux dimensions, la surveillance
et la propagande, qui donnent son second sens
à l’adjectif « orwellien ». Dans son
premier sens, il fait simplement référence
à Orwell et à son œuvre (on peut par exemple
dire « la langue orwellienne »). Mais c’est
aujourd’hui le second sens de l’adjectif
qui est bien plus courant. Une société qualifiée
d’« orwellienne » est une société dans
laquelle les autorités contrôlent la population
grâce la surveillance et à la propagande.
Certains disent que les sociétés occidentales
du XXIe siècle peuvent devenir véritablement
orwelliennes, voire qu’elles sont en train
de le devenir (c’est par exemple la thèse
de l’écrivain controversé Laurent Obertone
dans La France Big Brother). J’ai pour ma
part l’impression que la dimension chaotique
des grandes sociétés démocratiques et que
les innombrables résistances que rencontrent
les autorités politiques dans la réalité
concrète de l’exercice de leur pouvoir
— cela rend compliqué d’installer un
totalitarisme à la 1984.
17ème référence : L'Attrape-cœurs (1951),
J. D. Salinger
Réussir à percer est particulièrement difficile
pour un écrivain. Donc lorsqu’un auteur
réussit enfin à vivre de sa plume et à
obtenir la reconnaissance du public, il est
au moins soulagé : les jours de galère sont
derrière lui. Mais Jerome David Salinger
— qu’on abrège usuellement en « J. D.
Salinger » — est un écrivain allergique
à la célébrité. Sa vie change à 32 ans
lorsque ce roman devient un best-seller. Il
ne peut plus mener une vie normale à New
York, donc il déménage dans un État rural,
à plusieurs centaines de kilomètres au nord
de la capitale culturelle des États-Unis,
dans une petite ville de 1500 habitants. Il
y vivra reclus, loin de toute exposition médiatique.
Et étant donné la logique du désir humain,
ce choix d’être inaccessible fera de lui
un auteur mythique.
Mais pourquoi ce roman est-il incontournable
dans la littérature et la culture occidentales
? Parce qu’il symbolise la crise d’adolescence.
Il est également emblématique du fait que
les questions liées à l'adolescence, comme
la rébellion contre l'autorité et l'exploration
de l'identité — ces questions deviennent
des thèmes culturels fertiles à partir des
années 1950 (le roman paraît en 1951). Bien
sûr, ces thèmes s’inscrivent dans la révolution
culturelle occidentale des Trente Glorieuses.
Des hommes réputés rigides comme George
Bush senior ou Bill Gates citent ce roman
pour paraître plus ouverts d’esprit (enfin,
c’est ce que moi je soupçonne).
Le titre de ce roman renvoie indirectement
au mal-être adolescent. Pour le comprendre,
il faut analyser le titre anglais, « The
Catcher in the Rye ». « The Catcher », c’est
celui qui attrape, l’intercepteur, le gardien,
le sauveur ; « the Rye », c’est le seigle,
la céréale résistante au froid qui sert
à faire du pain et du whisky — et « the
Rye » peut également désigner un champ
de seigle. Donc « The Catcher in the Rye
», c’est le gardien du champ de seigle.
Cette image est issue d’une chanson enfantine
populaire. Le protagoniste du roman entend
cette chanson, et il fantasme sur le fait
de sauver de jeunes enfants qui jouent dans
un champ de seigle près d'un précipice.
C’est une métaphore : le précipice symbolise
la corruption du monde adulte, et le désir
d’empêcher les enfants de tomber dans le
précipice symbolise le désir de préserver
l’innocence de l’enfance de l’hypocrisie
du monde adulte. L’image du champ de seigle
est difficile, voire impossible à retranscrire
en français, donc le traducteur y a substitué
l’image du cœur.
Sur le plan de la forme, ce roman compte 250-300
pages selon les éditions. C’est facile
à lire, parce que Salinger simule la langue
parlée d’un adolescent américain du début
des Trente Glorieuses (c’est un peu l’argot
des ados). Du coup, il y a des tics de langage,
des mots approximatifs et des tournures familières.
Ce qui a surtout marqué le public à l’époque,
c’est la crudité du langage qui, en plus
du caractère controversé de certains thèmes
évoqués (comme la prostitution et la drogue)
— la crudité du langage a contribué à
l’interdiction du livre dans des établissements
scolaires. Le style n’est donc pas littéraire,
mais presque basique. L’adolescent s’adresse
directement au lecteur — c’est écrit
à la première personne du singulier. Il
y a beaucoup de phrases courtes.
Maintenant, quel est l’essentiel à retenir
concernant l’histoire ?
L'Attrape-cœurs raconte la fugue de Holden
Caulfield, un fils de la bourgeoisie new-yorkaise
de 17 ans. Chassé de son collège trois jours
avant Noël, il n'ose pas rentrer chez lui
et y affronter ses parents. Il vagabonde donc
pendant trois jours.
Le premier jour, il se fâche avec son colocataire
et prend le train pour New York (son internat
est à quelques centaines de kilomètres à
l’ouest). À New York, il loge dans un hôtel
miteux. Il fait une virée nocturne solitaire
: bars, alcool, femmes insignifiantes. Il
pose une question qui l’obsède à un chauffeur
de taxi : où les canards de Central Park
vont-ils une fois que le lac est gelé ? Cette
obsession est une métaphore célèbre du
fait que l’adolescent se sent enfermé dans
un monde qui n’est pas fait pour lui. De
retour à l'hôtel, Holden refuse les avances
d'une prostituée, ce qui lui vaut une altercation
avec son proxénète. La nuit se termine sur
des pensées suicidaires.
Après son histoire avec le proxénète, Holden
quitte l’hôtel le deuxième jour. Il achète
un disque pour sa sœur, et c’est en se
rendant à la boutique qu’il entend la chanson
qui donne son titre au roman. Ensuite, il
va voir une pièce de théâtre avec une fille
de son internat. Le rendez-vous tourne mal
: ils se disputent. Holden rentre chez lui,
et par chance, ses parents sont absents. Il
a cassé le cadeau pour sa sœur en errant
dans Central Park, mais il lui donne quand
même. Il passe la nuit chez son ancien prof
d’anglais. Mais il se réveille lorsqu’il
sent une main sur sa tête, et voit son prof
assis juste à côté de lui. Traumatisé
par les pédophiles qu’il a croisés au
cours de sa vie, il s’enfuit.
Holden passe la fin de la nuit à la gare.
Il demande à sa sœur de le retrouver au
musée pour des adieux. Elle vient, valise
en main, pour s’enfuir dans l’Ouest avec
lui. Mais finalement, Holden décide de ne
pas partir. Il offre un tour de manège à
sa sœur. On découvre à ce moment qu’Holden
est en hôpital psychiatrique. Et l’histoire
qu’on vient de lire est probablement ce
qu’il a raconté à un professionnel de
l’hôpital.
Comment résumer l’influence de ce roman
dans la littérature et la culture occidentales
?
Tout d’abord, il apporte un nouveau souffle
au genre du roman d’apprentissage — pour
rappel, un roman d’apprentissage est une
histoire qui suit le développement moral,
psychologique ou social vers la maturité
d'un personnage principal, généralement
de la jeunesse à l'âge adulte, à travers
une série d'expériences et d'épreuves.
Mais alors que les romans d'apprentissage
classiques suivent une trajectoire linéaire,
L'Attrape-cœurs est plus ambigu. Le personnage
de Salinger ne trouve pas de réponses simples
à ses questions existentielles ; il demeure
en conflit avec lui-même et avec le monde
qui l'entoure jusqu'à la fin. Il est un des
premiers antihéros adolescents de la littérature
moderne.
Seconde raison de l’influence de ce roman,
il symbolise la crise d’adolescence. Holden
est un être très sensible qui ne veut pas
se compromettre avec la société. Mais il
faut dezoomer pour comprendre son comportement.
Après la Seconde Guerre mondiale, les adolescents
commencent à être considérés comme un
groupe social distinct. Concrètement, ils
sont plus visibles parce qu’ils représentent
un groupe de consommateurs à part avec ses
propres goûts culturels, et surtout avec,
désormais, un pouvoir d’achat, car la prospérité
permet aux parents de gâter leurs enfants
(d’ailleurs, le héros du roman fugue…
avec l’argent de ses riches parents). L'Attrape-cœurs
est un peu à la littérature ce qu’est
La Fureur de vivre, avec l’adolescent turbulent
incarné par James Dean, au cinéma.
18ème référence : Le Vieil Homme et la
Mer (1952), Ernest Hemingway
Au début des années 1950, le journaliste
américain James Michener est en Corée pour
couvrir la guerre. Un jour, alors qu’il
n’est pas loin des combats, un homme lui
remet rapidement une enveloppe. Le magazine
Life, qui est un des plus diffusés aux États-Unis,
où il est une véritable institution culturelle
— le magazine Life demande à James Michener
de préfacer un nouveau roman. Bien sûr,
il doit d’abord le lire. Il se plonge donc
dedans et, il dira plus tard qu’il n’entendait
plus les obus passer au-dessus de sa tête.
Il n’était plus à la guerre en Corée,
mais à Cuba, à la pêche avec un vieil homme.
Ce roman est incontournable parce qu’il
représente la révolution du style qui se
produit au milieu du XXe siècle. Pour faire
simple, Hemingway adapte la prose romanesque
à la culture de masse. Son style, qui réussit
à être profond tout en étant minimaliste
et direct, le rend accessible à un large
public. Il reçoit le prix Nobel de littérature
en 1954, je cite, « pour le style puissant
et nouveau par lequel il maîtrise l'art de
la narration moderne, comme vient de le prouver
Le Vieil Homme et la Mer » (l’année précédente,
ce roman avait déjà valu à Hemingway le
prix Pulitzer, l'une des récompenses les
plus prestigieuses aux États-Unis). On peut
également dire que Le Vieil Homme et la Mer
est un roman emblématique de la démocratisation
de la littérature aux États-Unis, le pays
qui produit la culture dominante en Occident
à partir de la seconde moitié du XXe siècle.
Concernant la forme, c’est un des romans
les plus courts qui ait jamais reçu certains
des prix littéraires les plus prestigieux
: autour de 130-140 pages selon les éditions.
Comme je viens de le dire, la prose est très
simple. La plupart des phrases sont courtes,
et leur structure n’est jamais compliquée.
Hemingway se permet même des choses que les
manuels de style déconseillent (à raison),
comme des répétitions de mots d’une phrase
à l’autre, ou l’accumulation des « et
» (qui ne fait pas terrible à la lecture,
je trouve). Mais il crée des images puissantes,
rendues d’autant plus puissantes par le
contraste avec le minimalisme de la prose.
Voici par exemple comment il décrit le vieil
homme au début du roman : « Tout en lui
était vieux à l'exception de ses yeux qui
avaient la couleur de la mer et qui étaient
joyeux et invaincus ». Hemingway a élaboré
une théorie pour expliquer la puissance de
son style minimaliste : la « théorie de
l’iceberg ». Selon cette théorie, une
histoire est comme un iceberg : seule la pointe
est rendue visible par la prose, mais il y
a beaucoup plus en dessous. Un style à la
fois simple et précis permet au lecteur de
plonger plus profondément pour découvrir
les couches cachées de sens.
Maintenant, je vous résume rapidement l’intrigue.
L’histoire se passe à Cuba, où Hemingway
a longtemps vécu, y compris pendant la révolution
cubaine (qui s’étend de 1953 à 1959).
Le vieil homme du titre est le pêcheur Santiago.
Il est ami avec un jeune garçon, Manolin,
qui est son partenaire de pêche. Mais après
84 jours sans prise, Manolin doit quitter
Santiago pour un bateau plus chanceux. Cela
ne l’empêche pas de continuer d’aider
son ancien partenaire : il répare les filets
du vieil homme et partage ses repas avec lui.
Voulant en finir avec sa malchance, le vieil
homme décide de tenter sa chance loin dans
le golfe.
Le 85ème jour, il accroche un énorme marlin.
On trouve ce poisson puissant dans les eaux
tropicales. Il est un peu un trophée ultime
dans la pêche sportive. Les pêcheurs du
Golfe du Mexique (qui sépare Miami et Cuba)
rêvent de capturer ce poisson légendaire.
D’ailleurs, l’équipe de baseball de Miami
s’appelle les « Marlins de Miami ».
Je reviens au roman. La lutte entre l’énorme
marlin et le vieil homme est épique. Trois
jours durant, Santiago endure la faim, la
soif et la douleur. Il parle même à son
adversaire qu’il respecte. Il parvient finalement
à le tuer. Mais il y a un souci : il ne parvient
pas à hisser l’énorme marlin à bord de
sa petite barque.
Se produit alors ce qui symbolise les revers
de fortune : les requins se pressent autour
de la petite barque. Le vieil homme se défend
contre leurs attaques répétées malgré
son extrême fatigue. Grâce à leur nombre,
les requins finissent par dévorer le marlin.
Il ne reste plus que la tête, que le vieil
homme ramène au port en guise de trophée.
Son ancien partenaire, le jeune Manolin, est
impressionné. Il décide de revenir pêcher
avec le vieil homme.
Comment résumer l’influence de ce roman
?
Il y a tout d’abord l’originalité du
style que j’ai déjà évoquée. La prose
épurée d’Hemingway est un nouveau modèle
qui correspond à l’évolution du public
occidental et qui inspirera beaucoup de romanciers.
Comme l’avait anticipé Jack London au début
du XXe siècle, la production et la consommation
de masse poussent à la simplification du
style et à l’économie de mots. Le rôle
emblématique d’Hemingway dans cette évolution
illustre aussi l’influence de la presse
et du journalisme sur le genre romanesque.
Quelque part, les romanciers se mettent à
écrire comme des journalistes.
Une autre dimension essentielle de l’influence
de ce roman est sa métaphore de la condition
humaine. Le destin du vieux pêcheur cubain
est une allégorie de la bravoure et de la
volonté humaines, vaincues mais non détruites
par les forces meurtrières de la nature.
La plus célèbre citation du roman est « Un
homme, ça peut être détruit, mais pas vaincu
». La morale est simple : la sagesse réside
dans l'humilité.
Enfin, une autre dimension essentielle de
l’influence de ce roman est qu’il revalorise
le potentiel esthétique de la nature, et
plus particulièrement de la relation de l’homme
à la nature. C’est le premier livre que
j’ai accepté de lire sur la recommandation
de mon père, qui est un passionné de pêche.
Certains lecteurs trouvent que l’histoire
est trop ennuyeuse, mais les personnes sensibles
à la beauté de la nature, en particulier
de la mer, les personnes qui ont déjà pris
du plaisir à pêcher ou à naviguer peuvent
retrouver ce plaisir en se plongeant dans
Le Vieil Homme et la Mer.
19ème référence : Lolita (1955), Vladimir
Nabokov
Ce roman a été écrit en anglais et publié
pour la première fois en français. Mais
attendez… « Vladimir Nabokov », ça sonne
quand même franchement russe… Effectivement,
l’auteur est bien russe. Mais pas n’importe
quel Russe : il est le rejeton d’une riche
famille de la noblesse russe. Donc il n’a
pas été éduqué à l’école publique
du quartier. Alors qu’il a 6 ans, sa famille
passe un bref séjour à la campagne, et là,
son père découvre quelque chose qui heurte
profondément sa sensibilité de patriote
russe : Vladimir et son frère sont capables
de lire et d’écrire en anglais, mais pas
en russe ! En fait, ce n’est pas étonnant,
parce que ce sont des préceptrices anglaises
qui éduquent ses fils au quotidien dans l’hôtel
particulier de la famille à Saint-Pétersbourg.
Cette éducation ultraprivilégiée donnera
à Vladimir Nabokov une telle aisance avec
la langue anglaise qu’il écrira, lui, un
Russe dont la famille a fui l’URSS, un des
plus grands chefs-d'œuvre de la littérature
américaine.
Mais ce n’est pas ça qui rend ce roman
incontournable. Lolita est célèbre parce
qu’il est un des romans les plus scandaleux,
sinon le plus scandaleux de la littérature
occidentale. En effet, son thème touche à
un interdit anthropologique, la pédophilie.
C’est ce qu’il représente dans la littérature
et la culture occidentales : une histoire
d’amour pédophile. Le scandale et l’influence
de ce roman ont été tels que son titre est
devenu un nom commun (c’est ce qu’on appelle
une « antonomase », la figure de style qui
consiste à se servir d’un nom propre comme
d’un nom commun, ou inversement). Une « lolita
», c’est une pré-adolescente sexualisée
par le regard d’un homme mûr. D’ailleurs,
ce roman a popularisé un autre terme qui
désigne la même chose, la « nymphette », formée
à partir de « nymphe », qui désigne une
jeune fille gracieuse en référence aux divinités
féminines de la mythologie grecque, et du
suffixe « -ette », qui signifie que la chose
est plus petite.
Concernant la forme, il y en a pour plus de
500 pages dans la version française, donc
c’est quand même pour les courageux. Le
parfum de scandale et le caractère contemporain
de l’histoire aident à conserver l’attention
du lecteur. Seulement, le style de Nabokov
risque de rebuter un lecteur qui n’est pas
un fan de littérature. Certes, Nabokov écrit
très bien — mais souvent « trop bien », c’est-à-dire
avec une sophistication excessive. Lorsque
j’ai lu ce roman il y a 15 ans, je tenais
un petit carnet dans lequel je notais les
mots que je n’étais pas capable de définir
précisément à la lecture. Eh bien je n’ai
pas arrêté d’ajouter de nouveaux termes
en avançant dans Lolita. Nabokov se sert
de mots rares et précis, notamment pour décrire
le physique de la pré-adolescente et l’obsession
de l’homme mûr. En plus de l’excessive
richesse du vocabulaire, les phrases sont
longues et structurées de manière compliquée.
Les paragraphes aussi sont parfois longs.
Enfin, les nombreuses allusions ou références
culturelles, notamment littéraires, compliquent
encore la tâche. En conclusion, c’est de
la littérature de haut niveau, qui demande
un certain effort de lecture.
Je passe au résumé de l’intrigue.
Le livre se présente comme la longue confession
rédigée par un meurtrier avant son procès,
un dénommé Humbert. Comme il est mort d’un
infarctus quelques jours avant le début du
procès, un ami de l’avocat a pris l’initiative
de publier la confession.
Humbert, l’auteur de cette confession (et
donc narrateur), est né à Paris en 1910.
Prof de littérature, il est un homme séduisant.
Il est conscient de son attirance pour les
jeunes filles qu’il appelle les « nymphettes
». Après son divorce, il quitte l’Europe
pour les États-Unis, où il peut hériter
d’un oncle. Cherchant un lieu calme pour
étudier, il prend une chambre chez une femme
qui a une fille de 12 ans. C’est justement
la vue de cette « nymphette » en train de
bronzer sur la pelouse qui l’a décidé
à loger dans la maison, car elle lui rappelle
une amie de 13 ans qu’il avait aimée passionnément
lorsqu’il avait lui-même 13 ans (là le
narrateur donne une justification psychanalytique
à son attirance pour les pré-adolescentes).
Il fait tout pour se rapprocher de la fille
de sa logeuse, qu’il surnomme « Lolita
». Mais c’est la mère qui tombe amoureuse
de lui. Alors il accepte de l’épouser pour
rester près de la fille. Seulement, sa nouvelle
femme découvre son journal intime, où elle
apprend qu’elle le dégoûte et que sa fille
l’attire. Elle s’enfuit alors pour le
dénoncer, mais elle est tuée par une voiture
en traversant la rue. Humbert devient donc
le tuteur de Lolita. Il va la récupérer
au camp de vacances en lui faisant croire
qu’il la conduit auprès de sa mère hospitalisée.
Ils passent la nuit à l’hôtel, et ils
ont leur premier rapport le matin suivant,
à l’initiative de Lolita, d’après le
narrateur. C’est seulement après qu’il
lui apprend la mort de sa mère.
Ensuite, ils voyagent pendant un an dans les
États-Unis, ce qui permet à Nabokov de décrire
l’Amérique des années 1940. Ils demeurent
quelques mois dans une ville moyenne, où
Lolita retourne au collège. La jalousie de
Humbert crée de nombreuses disputes. Ils
reprennent la route, et au cours de ce nouveau
voyage, Lolita s’enfuit avec un amant du
même âge qu’Humbert. Il la cherche partout,
mais au bout de trois ans, il renonce. Il
a finalement de ses nouvelles par une lettre
: elle lui écrit qu’elle est mariée et
enceinte ; et elle lui demande de l’argent
afin de s’installer avec son mari. Il se
rend chez elle, mais comme le mari n’est
pas l’homme qui lui a « volé » Lolita,
et comme celle-ci repousse ses avances, Humbert
lui donne de l’argent et repart le cœur
brisé. Mais il a quand même réussi à lui
soutirer le nom de l’amant avec lequel elle
était partie. Alors il le retrouve et le
tue de plusieurs balles. C’est pour ce meurtre
qu’il est en prison, où il livre sa confession.
Je vous parle maintenant des dimensions essentielles
de l’influence de ce roman.
Sur le plan littéraire, la narration est
innovante. Nabokov crée un narrateur qui
manipule le lecteur comme il manipule les
autres personnages. Humbert veut faire croire
que c’est Lolita qui l’attire à elle
et qu’il ne s’agit pas de pédophilie.
Si on ne saisit pas cette spécificité de
la narration, alors on voit le roman comme
une apologie de la pédophilie (alors que
Nabokov répète lui-même dans la préface
que son roman n’est PAS cela). Certains
critiques ont par exemple résumé le livre
en disant « la virtuosité littéraire au
service de la pédophilie ». Mais bon, c’est
vrai que l’innovation narrative de Nabokov
est subtile — et donc certains lecteurs
se font effectivement manipuler par le narrateur
!
Sur le plan littéraire, ce roman est également
emblématique d’un refus de la tendance
dominante à la simplification de la prose.
Sur le plan plus largement culturel, Lolita
incarne la transgression de la morale sociale.
Le manuscrit a été refusé par les éditeurs
américains qui craignaient d’être ruinés
par les poursuites judiciaires ; puis censuré
en France un an après sa sortie. Mais le
scandale est toujours vendeur : plus de 100
000 exemplaires écoulés en seulement 3 semaines
lorsqu’il paraît enfin aux États-Unis.
Comme les éditeurs comprennent le potentiel
financier de la controverse, ils misent sur
des couvertures suggestives. Le célèbre
réalisateur Stanley Kubrick reprendra la
même recette, sept ans après la parution
du roman à Paris, pour son adaptation cinématographique
: l’affiche du film présente une jeune
fille aux lunettes en cœur et une sucette
à la bouche.
20ème référence : Sur la route (1957),
Jack Kerouac
C’est ce roman qui m’a donné envie de
voyager à la fin de l’adolescence. Et je
ne suis pas le seul. Je me souviens d’une
conversation avec un jeune ingénieur australien
et ses amis dans une piscine à Las Vegas.
Eux aussi avaient été inspirés par ce livre.
Donc ils avaient loué une voiture pour reproduire
les voyages racontés par Jack Kerouac. Et
ils sont nombreux, les jeunes Occidentaux
à avoir eu cette idée, car ce roman est
à l’origine du mythe du road trip (« aventure
sur la route » ou « voyage en voiture », en
français). Un road trip, ça consiste à
partir sur la route sans itinéraire précis,
pour explorer de nouveaux lieux, rencontrer
de nouvelles personnes et vivre des expériences
inédites (c’est le voyage lui-même qui
est important, pas la destination).
Mais l’influence de ce roman ne se résume
pas à cela. En effet, le road trip symbolise
plus généralement la rupture avec le mode
de vie confortable, prévisible et insipide
de l’homme ordinaire de la société de
consommation occidentale. À cet égard, Sur
la route annonce la révolution culturelle
des années 1960 parce que ses héros sont
de jeunes Occidentaux qui sacrifient leur
confort matériel pour vivre des expériences
significatives. Sur la route est plus précisément
le roman emblématique de la Beat generation,
le mouvement culturel des années 1950 à
l’origine de la culture hippie des années
1960. La liberté et l’anticonformisme qui
émanent de l’histoire fascineront des générations
de jeunes lecteurs jusqu’à aujourd’hui.
Sur le plan de la forme, ce livre compte entre
300 et 400 pages selon les éditions. Il est
accessible, même pour un lecteur de 2023.
Le style est simple et fluide, parce que Kerouac
a écrit le roman sous l’emprise de stupéfiants
en seulement trois semaines (ce qui fera dire
à Truman Capote, un autre grand romancier
américain, que ce n’est pas de l’écriture,
mais de la dactylographie). L’autre anecdote
célèbre, c’est que Kerouac a écrit la
première version du roman sur un rouleau
de papiers attachés de 36 mètres. C’est
un choix original, drôle, et même mythique
— mais cela n’a pas disposé les éditeurs
à accepter le manuscrit. En termes d’expérience
de lecture, cela crée une sensation de flux
continu. La fluidité du style de Kerouac
est originale parce qu’il combine de manière
hachée des phrases longues et abruptes. Ce
style spécial s’inspire à la fois du rythme
d’improvisation du jazz et de la poésie
traditionnelle japonaise (les haïkus).
Je passe au résumé de l’intrigue.
Le roman raconte les voyages à travers les
États-Unis de deux amis, Sal, le narrateur
et alter ego fictif de Jack Kerouac, et Dean,
l’alter ego fictif de l'écrivain Neil Cassady.
Sal commence par raconter leur rencontre à
New York. Tout juste sorti d’une école
pour jeunes délinquants, Dean vient découvrir
la vie culturelle de New York. Sa folie fascine
Sal et stimule son désir d’aventure. Dean
rentre à Denver (sa ville natale, au centre
des États-Unis) ; puis Sal le rejoint en
auto-stop et en bus (ce qui lui permet de
rencontrer d’autres marginaux sur la route).
Réunis à Denver, les deux amis assouvissent
leur passion commune : faire la fête, boire
et se droguer.
Ensuite, Sal quitte Dean pour la Californie.
Il y vit avec un vieil ami, puis a une brève
histoire d’amour avec une femme d’origine
mexicaine qui travaille avec lui dans les
champs de coton. Après la Californie, Sal
retrouve sa vie à New York.
Dean vient retrouver Sal dans la maison de
sa famille à Noël. Ils partent alors ensemble
dans la voiture de Dean pour rendre visite
à un mentor toxicomane à la Nouvelle-Orléans.
Ils traversent ensuite le Texas et l'Arizona
(ils longent le sud des États-Unis). Ils
volent de l'essence et de la nourriture au
fur et à mesure de leurs besoins, jusqu'à
ce qu'ils atteignent enfin San Francisco.
Dean préfère vivre avec sa femme, donc il
quitte Sal. Mais ils se retrouvent pour se
saouler dans les clubs de jazz de San Francisco.
Finalement, Sal, fatigué et ruiné par ses
voyages, retourne une nouvelle fois à New
York.
Ensuite, Sal veut commencer une nouvelle vie
à Denver. Mais comme il n’y parvient pas,
il part rejoindre son groupe d’amis à San
Francisco. Dean essaie d’y mener une vie
de famille normale. À l’arrivée de Sal,
il redevient fou, ce qui contraint sa femme
à le mettre à la porte. Les deux amis veulent
aller en Italie. Mais d’abord, ils passent
des nuits à boire et à se droguer dans les
clubs de jazz de San Francisco — puis rebelote
à Denver. Les pulsions de délinquance de
Dean les forcent à quitter la ville. Ils
font les chauffeurs pour un homme jusqu’à
Chicago, d’où — après, bien sûr, avoir
fait la fête dans les clubs de jazz de la
ville — de Chicago, ils reviennent à New
York. Dans cette ville, Dean met une femme
enceinte. Les deux amis ne verront jamais
l’Italie.
Ils sont ensuite attirés par le sud. Laissant
femme et enfant à New York, Dean part en
voiture avec Sal et un troisième larron : direction
le Mexique. Ils sont fascinés par la culture
et la liberté qu'offre ce pays. Sur le chemin
jusqu’à la capitale, ils s’arrêtent
dans de petites villes où ils trouvent de
la drogue et des prostituées à vil prix.
À Mexico, Sal contracte la dysenterie (une
maladie qui cause des diarrhées sévères),
donc Dean l’y laisse. Une fois rétabli,
Sal rentre à New York. Il découvre que Dean
y a épousé la femme qu’il y avait laissée
; puis qu’il l’a quittée pour retrouver
sa femme précédente, à San Francisco.
Le livre se termine par un voyage de Dean
à New York. Sal est désespéré par le désordre
et les ennuis liés à son mode de vie — mais
la folie de Dean l’inspire toujours. Seulement,
il ne peut plus le suivre à San Francisco.
C’est la dernière fois qu’ils se voient.
Maintenant, comment résumer l’influence
de ce roman ?
Sur le plan littéraire, il révolutionne
le style narratif. Kerouac baptise sa technique
d’écriture « prose spontanée » : comme
le nom l’indique, il s’agit de laisser
les mots couler spontanément et librement,
sans s'arrêter pour se corriger ou se censurer
— c’est le contraire de la méthode de
la plupart des grands romanciers classiques,
qui passent beaucoup de temps à retravailler
leur prose. Au contraire, la prose spontanée
de Kerouac demande à l’écrivain de capturer
ses pensées et ses expériences sous une
forme brute. L’intérêt de cette méthode
est qu’elle décuple la créativité dans
l’écriture (sans parler du fait qu’elle
économise beaucoup de temps et d’effort).
Elle inspirera des auteurs phares de la révolution
culturelle, comme Allen Ginsberg ou le journaliste
Hunter Thompson.
Sur le plan plus largement culturel, Sur la
route est le manifeste du mouvement de la
Beat generation, dont Kerouac est le chef
de file. L’anglais « beat », qui signifie
« battement, rythme », renvoie à quatre
idées : la tradition des vagabonds des trains
de marchandise qui sévissaient au XIXe siècle
aux États-Unis (tradition notamment décrite
par Jack London dans Les vagabonds du rail)
; deuxième idée à laquelle renvoie l’anglais
« beat », le fait d’être abattu par le
conformisme social de l’époque ; troisième
idée, le battement du cœur ; et enfin, quatrième
idée, le rythme musical du jazz, dont les
deux amis du roman, Sal et Dean, sont fans.
En tant que manifeste de la Beat generation,
Sur la route préfigure le mouvement hippie
et la révolution culturelle des Trente Glorieuses.
Cela en fait également un symbole de la remise
en cause du rêve américain, et plus généralement
du mode de vie sédentaire générique de
la classe moyenne occidentale.
Enfin, ce roman a encore influencé la culture
occidentale de deux manières plus spécifiques.
Il a lancé le mythe du road trip (comme je
l’ai dit tout au début). Il a également
joué un rôle significatif dans la mythologisation
de San Francisco comme une ville d'aventure,
de liberté et de contre-culture. Elle abrite
toujours la librairie et maison d’édition
emblématique de la Beat generation, City
Lights (qui a notamment édité des poèmes
de Kerouac). Il y a même un musée dédié
à la Beat generation, le Beat Museum, et
une « Allée Jack Kerouac ».
Si vous aimez l’esprit de cette vidéo — à
savoir découvrir des choses intéressantes
en allant à l’essentiel et sans se prendre
la tête — alors vous aimerez probablement
mon programme Culture Express.
C’est un programme méthodique pour devenir
facilement une personne cultivée en seulement
quelques mois.
Il couvre tous les domaines de la culture
générale : vous maîtriserez les connaissances
essentielles sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France, en économie,
en science politique, en psychologie, en science,
en littérature, en art, en religion, et en
philosophie.
Vous ne serez plus jamais à court de choses
à dire et vous gagnerez la confiance nécessaire
pour briller en toutes circonstances.
Vous pouvez en savoir plus en cliquant sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore en tapant directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Mais je pense que la meilleure façon de vous
donner une idée du programme est d’écouter
ce que les membres ont à en dire.
Valentine, qui reconnaît l’énorme quantité
de travail que ce programme a représenté
pour moi, dit que « c’est une véritable
mine d’or [...] L’essentiel est là, tout
est simple, pratique, très bien expliqué,
concentré, il n’y a plus qu’à recopier
et à apprendre. Ce travail est vraiment formidable
et passionnant. »
Maxence m’écrit directement dans les commentaires
en-dessous d’une vidéo du programme : « Ta
formation est vraiment remarquable. J'étais
un peu dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas, c'est un vrai travail
de synthèse que tu nous proposes et le format
vidéo est très adapté pour moi qui ai une
mémoire essentiellement auditive. Le choix
des thèmes et des chapitres est pertinent
et je trouve que tu as trouvé la dose d'approfondissement
parfaite ; à la fois précis mais sans fioritures
! »
Vincent, lui, fait carrément ma pub : « J’ai
d’ailleurs recommandé votre formation à
ma sœur qui travaille comme diplomate [...]. La
semaine dernière, elle a déjà eu l’occasion
de mettre à profit, dans ses discussions,
les connaissances que vous avez diffusées.
»
Vous verrez d’autres témoignages comme
ceux-ci dans les commentaires si vous rejoignez
le programme. Et si vous vous inscrivez, vous
bénéficiez d'une garantie résultats : une
fois que vous aurez terminé le programme,
je vous rembourserai intégralement si vous
estimez que vous n’avez pas acquis une solide
culture générale.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus, cliquez sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore tapez directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Plus de 800 membres ont déjà tiré parti
de ce programme, et je serais ravi qu’il
en soit de même pour vous.
Dans tous les cas, j’espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu.
Je suis Romain, et vous, vous étiez sur 1000
idées de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.